foreign
can I do yes
so we can get the uh
it is now 10 15 and welcome to
its abbreviation is CFL
if you came thinking this is a meeting
of the Canadian Football League you're
in the wrong room this is children and
family law
couple items from the chair as we begin
many of you new to the house went
through some training on raising your
hand in order to speak and how to speak
courteously and all of those things and
it takes a while to learn especially if
you've not been in an elected body
before so we'll walk you through the
process it'll take a little while to get
used to
secondly there are several possible
titles the one in the chair can adopt
for him or herself when I became
chairman of Health and Human Services
last term I asked the speaker if I could
be called illustrious potentate
that was rejected
I prefer the term Mr chairman not Mr
chair but Mr chairman is a personal
title
however referring to the office and not
the person we use the phrase the chair
as in the chair rules of the chair
appoints so the office is the chair I
prefer Mr chairman
three
OLS office of legislative Services is
unusually slow this year in getting the
bills drafted and sent to Community
Services where they are assigned to
committees and I'm trying very hard to
keep us going forward even if I don't
have too many bills that I can pick from
for next week's
committee meeting
so that we don't have a log Jam
if those bills are kind of delayed on
their end and delayed a bit on my end we
may have to have two meetings a week
before crossover and I don't want to do
that and I know some of you don't
because some of you have part-time jobs
and have made arrangements for Tuesday
and Thursday
four
as a courtesy
several days ahead of our committee
meetings where we will be having
hearings and even before the calendar
comes out I try to contact the prime
sponsor of a bill
regarding what I'm going to schedule it
I'll accommodate as much as I can
perhaps as an important witness who
cannot make it on the 17th and if at all
possible I can defer that bill to the
24th
perhaps the prime sponsor is going to be
prime sponsoring another bill in another
committee I can try to work around that
with the other committee chairman or
chairwoman so if I call you or email you
and leave you a message it's not only
courteous but it's in your best interest
to get back to me as soon as you can
because it may just well be about a bill
that you're I'm sponsor of or that you
are a co-sponsor and have a great
investment in it
five when we hear a bill
if it looks like we're pretty much in
agreement I'll ask for a show of hands
or nodding or whatever
that's not binding it's just a sense of
the meeting but what it will say to me
is we are pretty much in agreement about
this bill in which case we can go to
exec it right away there's no need to
wait on it we're not going to change our
minds we're pretty much in agreement
this is helpful it's very much helpful
so that we can have some bills to get
out of the way early on before the Log
Jam occurs just before crossover
sometimes however we're not going to be
in agreement
however we might come to agreement
in which case in my former committee I
would pick one or two Democrats and one
or two Republicans and ask them to get
together in person on zoom on a
conference call however they wish this
is not a 91a violation because it is
three or four or five people meeting
informally it's not a work session
and that way if they come back and say
hey we think we have found some common
ground now what I would be looking for
second best
is a compromise
first best would be a comprehensiveness
and many times in my former committee
what we did was we took the best of what
might be called a Democrat position and
the best of what could be called a
republican position and found that we
could come to Common Ground
sometimes it wasn't Democrat versus
Republicans sometimes it was some
Democrats and Republicans versus some
Democrats and Republicans but the people
would come back with a suggestion saying
you know if we had this amendment
I think we might have something worth
keeping here
now I will never ask people to violate
their consciences
but only about 10 or 15 percent of what
we do here is really core conscience
and some of the disagreements may be on
the best way to achieve something like
the best way
to help the child that is our goal
there may be different ways to get there
and some of those ways May Clash but can
we find some common ground
in my last committee we often did and so
a lot of our builds came out 21-0 or 19
to 2. we didn't start off that way but
we got there it's doable
now six
when we have public hearings
please talk to the people you know who
are going to come to the hearing and
testify please talk to them about what
our committee is and what our committee
isn't let me use an analogy
last term I also chaired the DHHS
oversight committee
in response to newspaper reports that
the New Hampshire Board of Medicine was
not transparent in reporting 20
malpractice settlements against a
certain surgeon you've seen that in the
paper you've seen that on TV I named a
special subcommittee to investigate this
seeming lack of transparency
there was a lot of anger out there
believe it there was a lot of angry
people in anticipation of our
subcommittee meetings a few individuals
called me
to see what punishment I would be
meeting out
to that surgeon
and my answer was I will be meeting out
no punishment
that is the job of the eternity General
and there is an investigator working on
this very thing that is not the job of a
policy committee or subcommittee
also there were a few individuals who
called me wanting to know how much
Financial relief we would be awarding
them because of the harm that happened
to a loved one incurring extra medical
bills and I said that is not our job
either that's where you hire a
malpractice lawyer and so if people come
to a committee and they're all
steamed up and expect our committee to
do certain things they need to know
there are certain things we do and some
things we don't do here let them know or
they will be disappointed or they'll be
angry at us
our task
referring out to my subcommittee again
was twofold review the laws and
procedures regarding how complaints
against Physicians and surgeons would be
received investigated and reported if we
thought the laws needed to be revised we
are a policy committee and we would
eventually work to get those laws
revised
if we concluded the laws were good but
they just weren't being followed
we can come up with a bill that maybe
put some teeth into what happens to
people who don't do what they're
supposed to but meantime that gets
kicked over to the Attorney General's
office
I don't even have subpoena power much
less than a standing army
and then the second thing that we did
was to make sure that the board of
medicines investigative unit had
sufficient funding to do their job
that's why sometimes a bill you will see
has FN after its number fiscal note
we've got to spend some money to get
done what we want our policy to be
so please let your people know
that if they're really angry because
their sis the system is broken or the
system has hurt them they may well be
right
but what we do is to try to address laws
it's not helpful
if somebody wants to testify
and it becomes a lengthy rant against
the system we could probably join them
in their rant we don't need to hear that
but they need to be heard there may be
other places other venues where that may
be the best place
time allotment
my heart goes out to people who have
taken a day off of work
maybe losing a day's pay or incur child
care costs for them to cuss to come here
to testify
only to be frustrated
in my first term in the house people
were allowed in our committee to testify
at length
and if you get 40 or 50 people signing
up to testify and the first five or ten
go on at length you can figure out what
happens I recall one hearing that
started at 1 pm
I look at my watch it's now 4 30. there
is still a stack of pink cards
some of the committee people have left
they have to go home
and so they didn't hear the testimony
others who wanted to testify and have
taken a day off of work have hired Child
Care have to go home
and they have wasted a day and maybe
wasted a day's pay
so in my committee last term I adopted a
rule that some others have adopted
the prime sponsor
of a Bill gets several minutes to
explain the bill a little bit longer if
the bill is complicated
I give the same amount of time to one
person on the opposite side of the issue
and then depending on how many pink
cards I have I will set a time limit
that is the same for everybody on either
side
we adopted a rule saying if a time limit
is going to be the same
and if the chair wishes to change that
the chair needs to Simply note in the
folder on the bill why you've heard my
blanket statement if we're going to have
a time limit it is after the first
person for in the first person against
has spoken
I think the best speech I heard last
year lasted 37 seconds
this person had written it out ahead and
got rid of extraneous words bunny trails
and so on and got it down to three
points Each of which was Illustrated
with two very helpful sentences 37
seconds she nailed it it can be done
what we also did
when we were giving people three minutes
is it two minutes 45 seconds we held up
a warning sign 2 45. and free an alarm
went off if somebody had a phone with a
buzzer
and at 3 10
and invited the next person to come up
that may sound cruel
that is quite the opposite it makes sure
that people who have come to testify are
heard when there's a lot of people
it is the way to go
so sharing last term only once did my
committee have a meeting that went on
past 4 30 and that was when the Senate
sent us over a Christmas tree bill with
87 parts
I have served notice that one's Dead on
Arrival if they pull that again
rarely did a Committee Member have to
leave and not hear people's testimony
rarely that a pink card signer leave
without testifying
and I think we had a second day of
hearings only once so that's what I like
to do and I think it works
now
let's get into a heavy thing
some of you know in fact this morning
earlier some of you even told me
this committee has not always been
looked upon with good regard
seven years ago
speaker Sean Jasper tried to abolish
this committee
few people I'm told
sign up to serve on it although a few of
you this is your first choice
or your first choice to come back but
still
the reputation
in the negative is not
because it's wrong to be passionate it
is good to be passionate about families
about children about a group in society
that believes it is being mistreated
it's not wrong to advocate for that it's
right
the problem is sometimes people forget
that we can disagree without being
disagreeable
those of us because I'm one who have
been an advocate know that sometimes you
can pound on somebody and wear them down
and I have done that that doesn't happen
in this committee
Advocate your position make your case
there will be people on the other side
just as passionate May believe for good
reason
even before I came into the legislature
I heard from people who told me they
were running for the house because they
have been badly treated by the judicial
system and wanted to do something about
it
so far so good
some of them went on to say I'm going to
conquer to straighten them out and they
came in with guns blazing you know that
almost never works
in fact sometimes it's actually
counterproductive
well last term we were quite passionate
about a number of the matters we
addressed in my health and human
services committee
but we always held each other in esteem
and treated each other with respect and
often we would in the beginning of the
term make sure
that a Democrat would invite a
republican to go out to lunch together
to get to know somebody in the committee
that is different
my favorite story in representative
McMahon you may remember this was
representative Jerry canerk a
progressive retired spine surgeon from
freedom
put his hand up
the chair Lucy Weber called upon him and
he
argued from the right
and I'm thinking who has crept into
Jerry's skull and changed him
well after he advocated the conservative
position I wasn't hearing much advocacy
for the opposite so I put my hand up and
I advocated for the left
why
the position wasn't being articulated
and then we all had a good laugh if
you've ever been in Debate Club in
school sometimes you're given
argue this point and you don't
personally agree with it but that's not
your job your job is to argue a
different point and sometimes by trying
to at least in our own minds argue the
other side we may see that there's some
points in it that might just work that
might lead to that comprehensiveness it
just sort of happens spontaneously but
sometimes we did it intentionally
now I have already made one ruling here
by virtue of my chairmanship it has come
to my attention that representative
Levesque was not taken out by this
committee for a drink on her 21st
birthday and we are going to rectify
that I'll make you that promise we're
going to fix that
all right before we do the the sort of
meet and greet
um
now is the time if you have any
questions I saw representative Moulton
you had your hand up
I did thank you Mr chair so Mr chairman
Mr chairman
um so I'm just wondering if if a
Committee Member was to miss part of
could you mention this in your in your
speech
um if someone was to miss part of a
committee meeting is it is it in YouTube
or something that we could watch it
later
like is it archived
I think so okay no that's good to know
I'm making every effort to be here for
every committee I actually got to work
uh shift switched so that I could be
here today I remember that thank you for
doing that I wish I could have
accommodate did you but there's two
other committees that want this room
right yeah no I understand that so
um so of course like throughout the year
I'm gonna do everything I can to be here
but just I'm just wondering just in case
and representative Moulton thank you for
as a rookie
your first time with a hand up knowing
to push the microphone button on you
know I've met people who have been here
a long time and they still have trouble
with that so thank you anybody else any
other responses to eye-opening Salvo
well if you think of something
representative
welcome back how long have you been away
um from this committee or from the
legislature from the house yeah I left
2016. that's when I came in I started in
1996. wow welcome back thank you and I
started on this committee and spent 12
years on this committee wow and then I
spent uh four years on uh
Municipal and County government so I've
had a good vacation and working on town
government the last you look all fresh
and ready for action I am good
um there was just one thing that you
said that I have to say I'm I'm so
opposed to okay not somewhat but I am a
post that's the straw poll idea on the
same day that someone presents a bill uh
because I think it's rude
White Road to the sponsor and I think
it's appropriate to give them the
opportunity to come in with an amendment
rather than quickly just shuffling it
out
if the sponsor of the bill
having seen the discussion is pretty
much in agreement with the sponsor's
bill still wishes to make an amendment
and says that to me I will happily defer
it's I've never seen it done that way
but it could be yeah we
well during some of my years here we put
it away with the
idea of quickly dismissing things out of
the out of politeness as much as
anything to the sponsors and gave them
the opportunity to come back with a
an amendment how would they want to come
back with an amendment with the sense of
the meeting is in pretty much full
agreement with what they gave us well we
always waited till executive session
understood make those uh decisions on
even even on a straw poll
um well I would be happy to be reminded
if it looks like the committee pretty
much agrees with the bill as we heard it
remind me please to ask the sponsor if
the sponsor is going to bring back an
amendment or not
and if the sponsor says I would like to
bring an amendment back
um through a member in the committee
here
um sure I can delay that well we we
usually move things pretty rapidly so as
soon as you're done with one you're on
to the next bill
and and the the sponsors Bill's gone and
sometimes they're off on another bill
I've done two bills or even three in
this day so it's just a matter of giving
them the opportunity to um
come back with a uh I say a member
amendments
uh I will ask someone anyway
argumentative about it just my my
experience appreciate that thank you
what else
now I'd like to do
the meet and greet
and
tell us your name
where you're from originally where you
live now
your education from where what was your
major
what your employment was or is
something about your family your reason
for being in the house and one or two
Curiosities about yourself and you get a
little over a minute to do it
and I'd like to start with the clerk
please
holy moly do I have to answer all those
questions uh Mr chairman well you will
be graded on it
all right online Peter Petrino from
Milford this is my uh third term I'm
originally from Boston you can probably
tell by the accent
graduate of uh Boston State College
Masters in Education and
minor in political science
uh I've been a resident of New Hampshire
since 1987 married and I have two
children
who I love very dearly three
grandchildren
uh happy to be returning here uh serving
as clerk on children and family law
and as I'm uh thinking I'm trying to
recall all the questions that you had
asked did I miss any
one or two Curiosities about yourself
I don't know I don't know High School
teacher for 41 years how about that
how about that good okay there you go
thank you very much
representative ball
good morning everyone my name is Lori
ball I am from Salem I am a retired
school teacher public school teacher
I've been in education for 30 years
Master's in education certified in four
areas of Education sorry it's all
education background
um but I'm a elementary school certified
special education certified I'm A
literacy specialist and emotional
behavioral specialist
I was actually excited to be on this as
well as I'm very much
um
concerned or interested in family court
and what happens I did have experiences
with some of my students with the court
system I was also a casa for a year
I am married for 40 years I have two
children and five grandchildren
and new learning experience I'm very
excited to be here
one or two Curiosities about yourself
I'm curious to see if I can do this
I'm confident I can but um yeah I it's
it's a new a new chapter in my life
since I'm now retired after being in
education for 30 years
thank you representative McMahon
chairman uh Charlie mcmanson name
um a lot of uh still New Hampshire grew
up I live in Windham New Hampshire
I've been uh in my 11th term now so it
was 20 years on Health Human Services of
elderly Affairs prior to that I was a
long-term border selective member in
Windham and I have a attitude of being
an aggressive Advocate with manners so
uh it's uh also voted by saying let's
get it done while we're young so that
puts me in direct conflict with uh many
people sometimes and you end up speaking
to an empty room but uh what I learned
over time is to accept and respect the
multiplicity of opinions and intentions
and there's also the public agenda and
then the hidden agenda and then doing
and working together then we can
accomplish something great for our state
and for our fellow citizens my
background is I'm married 40 years as
well I have three children one civilian
handicapped due to medical malpractice
and uh that's made me very sensitive to
the needs of those who have
quiet challenges that they keep private
in their homes but need assistance I
brought that to my attitude here at the
State House is listening first before
making pronouncements and
recommendations for Action so what and
also working together as a team so
throughout the collaboration to achieve
consensus and getting it done while
we're young so I'm looking forward to
meeting with everyone here
you bring a note not just of reality to
the subject but you also bring a note of
Realty don't you
thank you for your immediate recognition
of the obvious yes
I just have one unique thing is uh where
I learned a lot of this is an athletic
background that's where I learned a lot
growing up uh setting goals and even
getting knocked down a lot I was a
football player and I got as high as a
trial with the Dallas Cowboys and and
then learning from those who are
successful at the highest levels and and
the real commitment to Excellence to
earn consideration at the highest levels
is what I'd like to say we do here as
Representatives coming from our various
uh multiplicity of backgrounds and bring
that benefit to us all to learn from
each other is it fair to say
representative that you do not consider
yourself old but in fact what do you
consider yourself aggressively mature
thank you
thank you for remembering
we were on the same committee for six
years if you recall you remember your
presently yet again
representative Raymond
thank you that's hard to follow up after
that
um so I'm Heather Raymond uh I'm from
Nashua uh I grew up in Virginia though
so I have come quite a distance to come
up here to the Northeast where it's cold
I have a bachelor's of Science in
Psychology from Worcester State in
Massachusetts and I've been here in New
Hampshire since 2010.
um let's see professionally
um I was a forensic interviewer for our
state and local law enforcement when I
lived in New York state for several
years and that's interviewing child
victims of sexual abuse and severe
physical abuse then when we moved here I
worked for dcif until 2016 and then I
worked for Casa as a program manager for
a while and then I um you can all see I
have a cane if I seem a little unsteady
it's because I had brain surgery this
past year
um and so I stopped working and started
volunteering I'm on the board of
education in Nashua I was the president
of the board throughout covid and I'm on
the policy committee down there let's
see what else I've been married for 19
years I have two kids we're right in
that fun Middle School teenage beginning
of high school years so it's a little
intense in my house
and Curiosities about myself other than
my super cool cane and my still learning
to walk again
I paint and I have been working really
hard to redevelop that skill through
occupational therapy houses or floral
arrangements
um so I paint this is so silly I paint
mostly
um animals Birds
um I do portraits of people as well um
but to make money mostly people like Pet
Portraits I don't know why people would
rather have me pet their paints than
their kid their pets than their kids but
I do a lot of dogs so
they don't sit still for the primer coat
sometimes
thank you representative
Nelson the only one I've seen who has a
first name on your name plate
thank you Mr chairman that well we'll
start with that Curiosity first there
were two representative Nelsons when I
came here I was the second
representative Bill retired yes and so I
believe that's why my first name was
also included on there to not be
confused with him well there were two
named Pearson in the house right and I
think it's because we tend to swipe each
other's name plates regularly they
decided not to but go ahead
um thank you uh hello everyone my name
is Jody Nelson I'm from Derry I have
lived in Derry since 2008 moving up here
from Massachusetts with my husband of 22
years I have three children a stepson
who's 30 and my husband and I have two
children together our daughter's 21 and
our son is 12. he was a
very uh big surprise because I wasn't uh
supposed to be able to have any more
children after my daughter so it's
wonderful to be able to experience the
last one and fully enjoy him
um I
um I studied Elementary education at the
University of Massachusetts but I chose
to go into the corporate world most of
my experience in the corporate world was
in private Equity
a private Equity company in Boston where
I developed a very thick skin aunt which
is helpful here in this environment
sometimes so
um I uh
moved to the Northeast from Pennsylvania
when I was 11 and that's where my whole
family resides now and
I guess that's it other than my other
curiosity is that I'm a rabid hockey mom
thank you so much thank you
and representative Greg
thank you and yes you are apparently
from what I understand related yes I am
from that Greg family by marriage
um so uh no bloodline there but my I'll
go ahead and start with that so my
husband's cousin is Judd Greg his great
uncle was Hugh Greg
um we are the last Greg's in Nashua and
that's where I currently live um that's
not I wasn't lucky enough to be born in
New Hampshire
um but I was born in the midwest in
Illinois way south of Chicago so I
usually say St Louis because about a
half hour from St Louis and Southern
Illinois I'm proud to be from there um
even more proud to call this my home now
my husband was born and raised here
obviously with the Gregs
um but anyway my background is actually
I'm kind of you guys are at the
precipice of my what I call my new life
so I am a survivor of domestic violence
I have been out of that situation for
six and a half years
um it was an extreme situation I came
out of that and started advocacy to see
how many people I could help I have
helped women and men in three different
countries in over 30 States
um to get into safer places
um
which I have to look at a lot of
legislation in different states
um when I do that and so like what you
know what are they Bound by in that
particular state so when the pandemic
hit I had time to research here that's
what led me to um run for office to see
if we could move what I do in an
advocacy way to more of a legislative
level
um I call myself a trifecta mom I have
three kids they are my Trifecta also
amazing survivors and incredible humans
I'm always happy to talk about them
um Noah Ethan and Emma
uh the grand finale was the girl and I'm
teaching her to drive so bear with me
um if you want to know judgment that's
what you should ride with somebody
that's in uh driver's ed
um so that's so I was actually a
stay-at-home mom a very controlled
stay-at-home mom for um most of my life
and then six years ago I stepped out of
the shadows and said never again and so
I talked to groups about domestic
violence helped break the stigmas I have
a Blog that also does that
um you know and help individuals in that
aspect that won't change so I think they
call the official title a life coach
um and so uh yeah that's all kind of
curious right do I need two Curiosities
um I am my uh in my family line so
obviously the Gregs I married into but
in my family line I have another
um uh kind of political thing my uh I
don't remember how many greats but Uncle
whatever uh William Herndon helped get
Abraham Lincoln elected he was his law
partner and that is my maiden name is
Herndon in Illinois so
um you know always had a healthy
knowledge and respect for the political
system because of that so
wait
wow
thank you
thank you representative Seidel
good morning Mr chairman my name is
Sheila Seidel I'm from Goffstown I've
been in Goffstown for 30 years born and
raised in Manchester and then in Bedford
New Hampshire
um
born and raised in New Hampshire is that
better actually it does it for you if
you yeah
um I am a retired dental hygienist of 35
years having served mostly the Goffstown
Community Manchester area I'm married of
31 years my husband my children are 29
and 24. our son just moved out to
Seattle Washington
which I'm not crazy about he loves it
out there
um
I got I I'm here because I want to be a
voice for the unheard and our children I
think are a big part of that group
um I don't have anywhere near the
background of so many of you and and I'm
anxious to
start developing that background and
working with all of you to help our
children
about it Curiosities
I love the outside I love Landscaping
building rock walls making Rock Gardens
um just being in nature I'd rather be
out than in
wow
presentative Moulton
two for two on the microphone button
um I did not grow up in New Hampshire I
grew up in Philadelphia Pennsylvania in
the city in the city yep uh so
technically within the city limits but
kind of on the like Outer Edge uh if you
know where Bucks County is right right
there but within the city limits so
um I lived there until I was 17 and then
I moved to Florida I lived in Florida
for a few years about five years my
oldest son I was married we had the
ceremony in in Philadelphia but
um
but my son was born in Florida we just
kind of came up for the ceremony
um we were married my my son was born in
Florida and then we moved to Upstate New
York which is where my husband is from
and uh we lived there that's where I
went to college I where did you go to
college SUNY Plattsburgh SUNY
Plattsburgh yeah yeah so so right near
the Canadian border
um we lived there for about 10 years
um I I got my bachelor's in Biochemistry
and then decided I didn't want to work
in a lab
and I went back like immediately right
back uh for a bachelor's in nursing and
I have been working as a nurse since
2013.
um so 10 years now time really flies we
moved to New Hampshire in 2016 uh and we
moved to Manchester I've lived in
Manchester ever since 2016.
um
my so my second son was born when we
were living in Upstate New York
um so that I have two kids
and
um
I work in Boston now as a registered
nurse
and I chose child and family law because
representative Greg and I should talk
but basically uh I've been in the court
system since March because the well
April since the marriage is dissolving
and I am well versed in
a lot of these laws
um not necessarily them directly but
like what they mean and and who the
players are and things like that
um so I feel like
even though I have connections with you
know Health and Human Services I have
connections with education because I've
I've worked as a substitute
um for on and off for a couple years
um I just felt like right now my
services would be best served here so
this was actually my first choice a
couple of Curiosities yep
um I actually uh sew some of my own
clothing
um
I've made quite a few pieces uh but I I
don't plan to be a fashion designer or
anything but I can so
um I also like plants I
would like to go skiing if we ever get
some frozen precipitation
um I enjoy skiing a lot uh I kind of do
a little bit of everything so
thank you representative Perez
thank you
um representative Perez from Milford
District 43.
um I was born in El Salvador
um I migrated here when um I was not
even 16.
um I
I learned the language I learned the
culture
um
I'm a Survivor a child
of a sexual assault
I'm a Survivor of domestic violence
um in 2016 I decided to go with the new
Hunter family services and then I did a
training for 30 hours
um I started volunteering after I left
my domestic violence marriage
um and I start helping
um woman's imprison who didn't know how
to read or write in English or Spanish
um and for me that was the beginning of
healing
um
from the domestic violence and
everything that I have been going
through since I'm five years old
um
and I decided to get involved with um
with a lot of different
um
areas and not just
child services or domestic violence
because
um I think it's critical
especially in my culture
it is difficult for us to speak up
um a lot of times
um
our voices get silent because we're not
allowed to speak up about it especially
when is someone related to you who does
data sexual assault
um
and why I decided to be in this
committee and why I'm grateful to be in
this committee is because
not just because my own experience but I
since you know I'm five years old I have
so many uh things that I learned by
speaking with others other victims
listen and learn
and I believe that I have a lot to that
I can bring to this committee
um
in my background I
uh after I got divorced from my
ex-husband
because I was
um a little girl when I moved here he
didn't allow me to go to school because
he was afraid that I was going to find
someone else younger because he was 47.
um
so he never let me go to school
but when I got divorced I went back to
school
I
graduate from
High School
I went back to college I graduated with
three majors
I study small business management human
resources in accounting
and I'm close to finish my marketing
business and marketing degree from the
community college I work for the
or model company is a customer relation
for almost 11 years
um
I'm bilingual so my bilingual background
helped me a lot with being a customer
service
customer relation and then I work for
um alien candles and Milford it's a
human uh sources um
I help with um hiring
um
in in payroll and administrator
assistant for many years we're going to
need to move on thank you so much
representative panic
thank you my name is Sandra Panic from
Pelham New Hampshire Hillsborough
District One
I've been living in Pelham for
30 no since 1981
42 years I think that is I've been
married for 43 years
um
mother of two sons and one grandson I am
a gold star mom
um
I'm also
a my father was a victim of a mass
shooting when I was five years old
and
um
I am pro-second Amendment if he would
have been
he's already always taught me that if he
was
um had protection he could have
changed the outcome
and
um we've had you know he lived you know
you know we took care of a
a dad with
in a wheelchair for 36 years
um
so that's my sad story the good story
the good part of my life everybody has a
good story and a bad story is I did go
to California
I went to Orange Coast Community College
I decided to get out of there and come
back I grew up in I was born in
Connecticut I grew up in Massachusetts
went out to California
um decided I wanted to get into the
world of business
um I worked in the travel business I've
been all over the world
um
went back then then I had my children I
raised my children I was a stay-at-home
mom and then I went back to college and
I decided I still had that business part
in me and I was in the world of
alternative medicine I had a massage and
Acupuncture Center which I sold and then
I became a massage Chinese Cup being
educated and again I traveled all over
the world to teach that modality and now
I'm retired and here I am today
thank you you're welcome
representative Levesque
hello
um my name is that it's actually
Levesque the S is silent uh the French
Canadians like to do that with different
letters and they choose it at Raynham I
don't know why they just do
um so recipient
um I am born and raised in New Hampshire
I grew up in Barrington since I was six
months old I have been living with my
grandmother since I was
since 2019 uh when she passed and I've
been a caregiver for her and helping my
parents out with her as much as possible
um I uh was a girl scout since I was
five and I went all the way to high
school and now I have my own Girl Scout
Troop that I started when I was 18 when
they were daisies and now they are in
middle school so I have to deal with the
middle school age of
everything is terrible right now so
um but luckily I can pass it on to their
parents and be like here you go
um I started my journey in the state
house when I was 16 trying to end child
marriage here in New Hampshire I have
started a uh
talk about it all over the U.S it
brought attention to it
um that it is happening here in the US
and many other countries all around the
world and
um I
I'm currently working as training to be
in a optometrist in a local
um eye doctor's office in Barrington and
I also like to do art I do many
different things paint
I love film photography I love
um just going out and just taking photos
of basically nature and I don't
necessarily like taking photos of people
because people kind of get in the way of
the nature sometimes
um and I rather take a picture of what's
happening in the world uh right now I'm
getting into Political uh photography
going to rallies and taking photos of
what's happening here so hopefully
someday when I am 23 so I'm still trying
to figure everything out and what I want
to do with life and yeah
thank you
representative Bickford
you want to hear more
a little bit
all right uh let's see I think I told
you I I was hearing I started in 97 but
I've been off and on
I've been elected nine times now
um the legislature I've done a lot of
work in town government nine years as
Selectmen and presently I'm uh on the
planning board and the zoning board and
the budget committee
and trustee trust funds so I did choose
municipal government first and this was
my second choice so I was picked for
here
um I'm 71 years old I have five children
three grandchildren
uh unfortunately my son-in-law is in the
Coast Guard which means the
grandchildren travel all over the place
but here
um
except for one one's a Nottingham
um what else
um I own about her co-owned uh
about 450 acres of of uh land and uh my
passion is agriculture actually I've got
36 quarter firewood in the yard I go out
and uh last one was good time get a lot
of wood out fortunately
um
what else you want to know about me
curiosity
what's that a curiosity
how to pass on that one everything to me
is I'm curious about we'll find out
um as far as hobby that's my hobby is
get yeah you may
like I said I enjoy the agricultural
thing I don't enjoy games I I don't play
any games at all my father did my mother
didn't we we don't play Gods we don't
watch sports on TV or anything like that
we uh that's a curiosity right we like
we like doing things uh
for the hands
thank you
representative Grossman
well it's you you're up
we're learning
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm Gabby Grossman and I represent
Exeter and this is my third term serving
on children and family law and it's
actually quite an honor to be on this
committee and there's some nice faces
out there that folks that have come
before us before
um
I'm a mom to uh three boys I'm married
for 19 years my oldest son Eli is about
to turn 18 and he has a chromosome
duplication and autism
um and a Caesar seizure disorder
um
and he is my reason for beginning
advocacy work
back when he was first diagnosed with
autism and fighting for inclusion
in New Hampshire my background so I was
born in Germany I'm a military brat
um lived in Hawaii New York my dad was
in the Naval Academy in Marine Corps
served in Vietnam and passed away about
four years ago
my mom is German and they met in Paris
and
um
so I grew up back and forth every summer
going to Germany
um and went to school at Boston
University graduated in three years I
guess that's a curious fact and I have
my master's degree in education I was in
Middle School
um seventh grade middle school geography
teacher social studies in Boston Public
Schools Chelsea and Plymouth and then
when I had my son
um Eli and then I also have my
twins Oscar and Oliver Grossman my Obama
twins that's another curious fact I had
dinner with then Senator Barack Obama
and um I'm known as Obama Mama on the
Seacoast
um
and
when the pandemic started uh the week
the pandemic started my husband and I
joined a new adventure and bought a
campground in Ashland New Hampshire so
we live on the Seacoast
and so we own amesboro campground in
Ashland and it's a hundred sites about
50 seasonals and it's been quite an
adventure with three teenage boys so I
can relate to all the teenage it's a
definite transition
well I'd ask you if there's any
Curiosities in your life but I think
I'll pass I actually have one more this
is an important thing related to
business
um I'm also chair of the bipartisan
disability caucus so anyone looking to
join we will be having an event coming
up February 2nd and a meeting so come
see me
and I know that you've been a big help
thank you to that thank you so much
representative D Simone
thank you Mr chairman my name is Deborah
DeSimone
um my husband is Italian and the
Italians unlike the French like to
pronounce every letter
thank you representative D Simone for
that you're welcome
um
I'm in my uh beginning my eighth term
for Rockingham 14.
um Atkinson
I moved to Atkinson uh 38 years ago when
I saw the other country south of us
going really wrong
I have I have been married in in 13 days
we'll celebrate our 50th wedding
anniversary
um I am a survivor of childhood abuse
um I'm also an eight time Survivor of
cancer
um so if you can
survive child abuse you can survive
anything I guess because the cancer is
no match
um my sister unfortunately wasn't a
Survivor and she died at 22 and when she
died
I prayed God to take her and I prayed
that I would do anything I could
possibly do to help children and
families
from that moment on and that was well
over 40 years ago
and that's why I'm here
I'm also a
tax collector for the town of Atkinson
which I've done that job for 25 years I
graduated
actually from Salem State with a Nursing
degree
but I went into oncology and back in
those days everybody died so I left
I went back to college and got a finance
degree because even today most people
survive
regardless of what the financial
situation is
um I love this committee I've served on
this committee's
um for seven of the terms once I was on
Municipal and County
I came back
um I love I also am the chair of Family
Mediation and juvenile services
which encompasses the majority of
Rockingham County
um I love I'm like representative Nelson
she's a hockey mom I'm a hockey nam I
have two granddaughters
who play Ice Hockey competitively the
oldest one for nine years the youngest
one who's six for three years
um we love skating in winter sports
I despise the summer
so I'm a winter person so and that's
that's pretty much all it is
thank you
Vice chairman long
thank you Mr chairman uh my name is Pat
long I was born and raised in Manchester
and I represent Manchester
um I'm in my ninth term
uh at the age of three years old I was a
ward of the state I went to orphanages
and Foster homes and um
my education I graduated from the alleys
of Douglas Street High honors
um uh curiosity is uh I had a son
graduated from West High
uh Sony records signed him up he
traveled the world for 14 years never
signed that million dollar check so he
became an MMA fighter for seven years
um and now he's in San Francisco working
uh for a regional manager uh he's loaded
with tattoos a couple of hooks uh and I
blame the New Hampshire digital system
for for that uh
and that's it I also serve in Manchester
I'm a chairman of the board of
Manchester
thank you so much
Mark Pearson I was born in a Mill Town
in Massachusetts I knew that Italians
sounded all the letters and the French
didn't but I have obviously forgotten
both of those things
um many people know what acoa means it
means an adult child of an alcoholic I'm
an
acouh which is an adult child of Aussie
in Harriet I grew up in a functional
home in a neighborhood of functional
families that's probably my curiosity
I went to Williams I graduated in three
years I was elected to Phi Beta Kappa I
was an honors history and music double
major
I went to Oxford on a fellowship where I
got a master's degree and then I got a
doctorate in Boston University
um married to a family practice
physician I have three children my
daughter Jennifer runs a Cooperative
homeschooling Consortium my eldest son
Stephen is a Manchester firefighter Ward
2 and a representative of the House of
Representatives from Derry my youngest
son Michael is a corrections officer at
a Maximum Security Prison in New York
state I've been an Episcopal priest for
47 years part of that time was spent as
a graduate school professor
I presently have a small Church in
Kingston assisted by two other priests
who have other jobs one of whom Works
full-time with the developmentally
disabled which as you know
representative is one of my interests
I was awarded a milk Bank fellowship
with Deputy Commissioner Marissa Han
also was awarded and so we traips all
over the place learning a lot more about
Health and Human Services things I was a
member of the Health and Human Services
committee for six years the last two
years as chair and much of the DHHS has
to do with Health and Human Services the
rest of it has to do with children and
family law so here I am
uh curiosity I'm a classically trained
pipe organist and back when I could
practice two hours a day my last recital
was at the old North Church in Boston
the other Curiosities are I'm an eagle
scout
and I absolutely adore basset hounds
whether they're painted or not
Mr chairman if I may say that I grew up
in Stallone property just a couple of
steps away from the old North Church
wonderful yeah
one of my land to if I see I'll wait for
you in Charlestown
well that's the meet and greet and I'm
hoping we're going to have a lot of good
fun times with each other
and now we've got what I call the beauty
pageant and we'll be doing this probably
to begin the next three meetings uh I
must step out Mr Vice chairman at uh
just before noon I have a meeting with
the speaker
um so we could probably go to about 12
10 or so and I know we won't get to hear
everything from everybody we want to
hear from but we will make a good start
so uh who is up
anybody named Joe ribson come forward
does anybody qualify
to see if he passes the very first test
of sitting in that chair
he did it'll be one moment because I
have to hand out a bunch of papers as
well but good afternoon good morning
still Joe ripson director
you came here from New Jersey there's a
curiosity
we'll go in this way in case we're sure
there's a couple going that way
mistress
okay let's try again good afternoon
everybody Joe rip some director dcyf
wonderful yes those are extra thank you
wonderful to see everybody
um
with me today from DHHS I do just want
to introduce a couple folks we have Beth
margison she is our general counsel and
legislative liaison at dcyf so you'll
probably be seeing her quite a bit this
session and Marissa hen who is our
associate commissioner so you'll
probably be seeing her quite a bit as
well this session
um I've been here in New Hampshire for
five years came here from New Jersey
where I served as the Deputy
Commissioner of their Department of
Children and Families New Jersey set up
quite differently than New Hampshire
where you have similar to Massachusetts
a separate department for child
protection and children's Behavioral
Health whereas here in New Hampshire you
have kind of an umbrella Health and
Human Services Agency that does kind of
everything Health and Human Services
from Medicaid to Child Protection to
TANF to
everything you can imagine and then you
have different divisions within that
department that do all these separate
things dcyf is responsible specifically
for child protection and Juvenile
Justice and we've done a lot in the last
five years to try to change the way the
child welfare system in this state Works
a ton and I'm going to try to kind of
walk folks through what a lot of that
has been we're certainly not going to
get through all of it today and I am
happy and eager to pause at any point
that folks want to take questions of
course at the discretion of the chair or
the vice chair whoever's presiding at
the moment
so if we want to flip to the first page
just want to share a little bit about
what we're trying to accomplish here
um so overall you know what our what our
vision is at dcyf is that we want to see
that New Hampshire's children youth and
families are safe healthy and connected
right that's a much bigger Vision than
what a Child Protection Agency can
accomplish a much bigger Vision than
what a juvenile justice agency can
accomplish frankly it's a bigger Vision
than what the whole Department of Health
and Human Services can accomplish it's a
vision that requires Collective action
across the entirety of a state and when
we talk about connected the reason
that's important is that we know that no
child is successful without a family we
know that no family is successful
without a community folks need to be
connected to other folks they don't work
well when they're in isolation
and when we think about the way that
child protection and even Juvenile
Justice was structured here
um in the Years prior there were a lot
of uh I think
structural misalignments in the way that
we functioned
um
probably the biggest primary challenge
was that we were designed in a way to
only be reactive to abuse and neglect
and to not actually try to do or even be
authorized to do anything to help
families before they got to that point
so literally our child protection agency
was not allowed to offer a service to a
family until we completed an
investigation substantiated abuse or
neglect brought them to court got a
court order for a service and frankly if
you're doing all of that to get help for
a family that there's no way that you're
going to meet the needs of the people
that that you're serving right you need
to get to them a lot sooner than the
point of dragging them into court
and our Juvenile Justice System frankly
Works largely the same way and has
worked largely the same way right that
kids got the help that they needed once
they were found to have committed a
crime once they were arrested once they
were brought into court found delinquent
and then they get ordered to get
Behavioral Health Care treatment why
don't you just provide Behavioral Health
Care treatment at first right so a lot
of the work for the past five years has
been around reorienting those systems
away from being reactive to crisis and
using punitive interventions towards
identifying needs and meeting needs
that's a huge job and we're nowhere near
done but that's kind of the the
orientation of the direction we've been
moving for the last five years so this
first bucket here you know if we think
of all the things we're doing they kind
of fall in one of these two buckets to
the left the first one this idea earlier
supports the strengthen children and
families and what we're talking about
there is that we want to shift child and
family serving systems to be more
proactive and supportive and less
coercive
I know folks find that work coercive
uncomfortable sometimes my own staff
find that word uncomfortable sometimes
but that's the truth right the child
protection agency has the ability to
remove a child from a family that's a
scary thing that's going to make
families want to necessarily cooperate
Juvenile justice system has the
authority to impinge on the Liberty
rights of young people that's a scary
thing that's going to make them not want
to cooperate so if we're able to
identify their needs before we get to
that point of having to be kind of a
threatening presence then you're likely
to see better cooperation and better
engagement from families and hopefully
better outcomes
um the second piece of this which is
absolutely critical as well is that I'm
not so naive as to believe that we're
going to be able to prevent every single
family and every single kid from having
to require a deep end intervention it's
true that there are people that abuse
kids and do awful things and those kids
need to be protected sexual abuse occurs
physical abuse occurs those kids need to
be protected fortunately that's not the
most of what we see but we do see it and
when that happens we do need to be able
to intervene and protect those kids same
thing on the Juvenile Justice side we
know that there are some offenses that
happen that are really severe that need
to the community needs to be protected
from I'm not so naive as to think that
we're going to be able to eliminate all
of that with a snap of a finger and a
couple nice services but we can minimize
how often we need to use those
interventions by trying to help families
and help kids sooner so when we do need
to use the deep end of the system we
want to make sure we have the highest
quality supports and services for kids
and Families
and what this really is about a big part
of this has been around looking at what
our service system historically offered
and what it should offer
historically our model for services for
kids and families in dcyf
um used kind of three different levels
of services
that we called child health support
which is kind of low level intervention
home-based therapy which is a medium
level intervention and what we called
intensive service option which was a
high level intervention
there was no kind of specific modalities
no evidence behind any of these programs
nothing like that the rest of the
country had been studying different
modalities at work and have developed
evidence behind programs but New
Hampshire hadn't adopted any of those so
a lot of our work for the past few years
has been moving away from kind of the
historic model and moving into the
utilization of evidence-based models
that we know are effective at meeting
kids and families needs so as I'm
talking further through this I'm going
to be kind of talking about these two
big Ideas this idea of Shifting the
system more Upstream to identify and
support families sooner and the idea of
that when families do need deep end
intervention the types of things that we
do to help them have their needs met and
keep kids from coming back into the
system again
any thoughts on these big picture ideas
before I go deeper
great
so the first thing I'm going to talk
about is actually not even in dcyf and I
think I understand the chair has had the
uh the the brilliant foresight to invite
children's Behavioral Health to come
present so I'm not going to go deep on
this but the first big thing in
reforming child protection actually has
nothing to do with child protection and
Juvenile Justice it has to do with
actually building a children's
Behavioral Health Care System Something
New Hampshire didn't have five years ago
I'm sorry
uh put your hand up and I'll recognize
you yes representative Bickford welcome
back
hey man thank you very much Mr chairman
um don't forget that
um he's just going a little fast for me
that's all uh if he could speak just a
little slower absolutely I get this
the air conditioner yeah the New Jersey
mouth New Hampshire ears
that's right thank you okay over now so
um so yeah actually New Hampshire did
not have a children's Behavioral Health
Care system five years ago in fact if
you looked at the 10-year mental health
plan that was developed I guess 12 or so
years ago at this point the word child
was never used one time as if children
don't have Behavioral Health Care needs
um which is just baffling to me right
and if you look at you know what we did
in New Jersey what a lot of other states
have been doing is if you start to
identify and meet the Behavioral Health
Care needs of kids you can drive down
the needs in your juvenile justice
system and the needs in your child
protection system because so many of the
kids that show up there are just kids
that aren't having their needs met
elsewhere
so some of the biggest things that we
had to do in New Hampshire to fix Child
Protection Juvenile Justice was actually
building a children's Behavioral Health
Care system and I understand Rebecca
Ross from children's behavioral health
will be coming at a future meeting so
she'll go deeper on all that stuff I'm
not going to go super deep on that but
there's just a couple key points I want
to make big deal things that have been
done in the past couple years here right
rapid response that mobile crisis
services that launched last year that's
a huge huge deal for kids and families
and keeping kids stable in their home
communities
that we're actually using an assessment
nowadays to identify what Behavioral
Health kids what what needs are for kids
in Behavioral Health historically when
kids came to dcyf for child protection
and Juvenile Justice
if we were trying to determine where a
kid should be placed what type of
program they should be in there wasn't
actually clinical assessment done as a
kid of a kid they were just kind of
matching up kind of professional
Judgment of what they thought a kid
needed with what was out available in
the community a couple years ago we
started a new process called the cap
process so now all kids get a
standardized assessment
and all the all the new residential
programs again Rebecca will go deeper on
this but they all have contracts that
have specific evidence-based modalities
that go along with the types of
um the types of services that they
require based on what those assessments
have so that whole system's been
revamped yes chair uh wishes to ask
um I've seen the pendulum shift in other
areas of life from the professional who
eyeballs it to the opposite of this is
what the test says I'm hoping that the
appropriate adoption of evidence-based
things is not at the total expense of
the person who's done this for years and
can have a gut instinct oh yeah no it's
it is a process and actually if you look
at the way those the cat assessments are
in they're written with you know this is
kind of the range of recommendations and
especially when you're talking about
placement of a child in a residential
setting a lot of it is there's a little
bit of wiggle room in terms of whether
you can provide that clinical care in a
home setting with intensive Clinical
Services or in a residential setting
based on you know what the home
environment is as well so you know the I
don't want to get too deep but there's
five levels of care that are identified
in the cat assessment and really among
the first three levels if you have a
stable home setting you can really
provide that level of clinical service
within the home if you have a stable
home setting in the right clinician in
place so give some discretion within
there as well as you know what's the
what's the right way to make sure the
clinical needs are being met even in
terms of whether you're going to use a
program or whether you're going to use a
home
couple other big just key things
um the key service that's used for high
and moderate Behavioral Healthcare needs
is something called High Fidelity
wraparound Services there's a program in
New Hampshire called Fast Forward which
uses this model
that is I'm sorry we're on page four now
see people
jumping around that's a program called
Fast Forward
the model of High Fidelity wraparound
Services what they do is they have a
clinical person who leads the team and
they pull together the young person they
should always be at the table the family
they should always be at the table
whatever professionals are working with
them so if Child Protection or Juvenile
Justice is involved they're going to be
at the table but it's also entirely
possible that Juvenile Justice and Child
Protection are not involved
schools they should be at the table any
clinicians treating the family and any
natural supports so anybody the family
relies on that could be grandparents
Aunts Uncles neighbors faith community
members whomever it is that family
identifies as important and the goal is
that you have that team of people try to
figure out how do you support this kid
and how do you support this family to
keep this kid in their Community
receiving the support that they need and
how do you keep this family getting the
support that they need and using a
service like that for many many families
is enough to keep a kid out of like a
residential stay and something like that
and then there's a separate variation on
this that we created called Trek here
and I'm not remembering what the acronym
stands for right now but essentially
what Trek is is it's that same exact
service but it's for when a kid is in
residential placement
and what they do is they work with that
same team of people to help put together
a team to make sure that when the kid
comes home for residential they stay
home from residential that they're able
to go back to their community and be
safe and supported and not end up going
back into the system over and over again
the way that we've historically seen
those are massive changes to the system
that have occurred over the past few
years
you know fast forward was a program that
five years ago didn't serve anybody and
now is serving close to 500 kids at a
time and Trek serving currently I think
120 kids at a time overall rate the need
for these services are probably greater
than we currently have capacity for but
but you know a lot of a lot of really
great work is happening there and a lot
of kids who otherwise would have been in
the Juvenile Justice System I think are
showing up over in this system instead
which is exactly what we're talking
about getting kids and families into a
place where their needs are met in a
non-coresive supportive way where kids
and families are in the driver's seat
with clinicians instead of having courts
and state employees and other people
driving their lives
um I'll skip over the rest of this page
four just in interest of time
so last year we started what I think is
one of the most exciting projects
um that I've been part of in my career
that I think is going to end up proving
the next few years to be the model for
the country in terms of trying to kind
of redirect how Juvenile Justice works
there was a bill that was passed called
it was Senate Bill 94 sponsored by
Senator Carson passed I think
unanimously you know certainly in this
chamber a couple years ago in this
committee a couple years ago when it
came through I think it might have
actually been unanimously on the floor
as well
and what Senate Bill 94 did was it
created a new process whereby when kids
have contact with law enforcement
law enforcement offers that child an
opportunity to be referred to us to do
an assessment
and the prosecution of that case gets
paused for 30 days while we do the
assessment there's an exception in there
if it's a if it's a critical high-risk
situation right if this is a a serious
violent crime for which law enforcement
feels that they need to remove the child
and detain them immediately to keep the
community safe there's an exception for
that but otherwise and that's rare right
there's there's thousands of arrests
every year
only a handful are like those types of
serious violent crimes so serious
violent crimes there's an exception but
for everything else it goes through this
process where the family's given an
opportunity to have an assessment done
and we use What's called the cans
assessment child adolescent needs and
strengths
the reason we chose the cans is that one
it inventories all different types of
needs and domains of kids to help you
identify what's going on two it's also
the same exact tool that's already used
in the children's Behavioral Health Care
system and we wanted to use the same
tool across multiple systems so that
people can communicate with each other
understand kids needs and be able to do
planning for kids additionally because
you'll see kids and families pop up in
different systems at different times and
if you're using a common assessment that
makes planning better and easier over
time so what we do is we use this cans
tool and then we from that develop our
recommendations is this a child who
needs to go to court because we think
that this is a situation that's so
serious and a family and a child that's
not willing to engage in an alternative
you know solution to this problem or is
this child and family who were able to
provide services for in the community
can we get them involved in that fast
forward program I was just talking about
can we get them involved in Outpatient
Therapy can we get them involved in a
local diversion program can we get them
involved in a Boys and Girls Club can we
get them involved in some of these kids
just need some type of pro-social
activity like a little league or
something to keep them busy and occupied
in something productive and healthy
so this started here in New Hampshire in
January and one third of the state last
January we rolled out to the next third
of the state in
July and we finished rolling out
Statewide
in October so early data from this is
really really promising
that's what you'll see on Page Six
so you'll see the numbers here a little
bit skewed based on the rollout schedule
but we are now Statewide and to date
we've done a little over a thousand
assessments across the across the state
Manchester was in the last group which
is obviously our biggest
District so I do anticipate the annual
volume will probably be you know closer
to maybe
1600 to 2000 assessments a year when we
see it
what you see on the right is was the
service was the referral accepted by the
family so when law enforcement makes
this referral the families it's TR it's
entirely voluntary a family can say no I
don't want to do this and the law
enforcement has a prerogative to go
forward and prosecute the old way or
they can participate and we're seeing 72
percent of the families being willing to
engage in that service up front which I
think is a pretty a pretty good
engagement percentage for a brand new
service like this could you break out
the non-accepted category in terms of
the family did not accept what was
offered but law enforcement said but
you're going to versus law enforcement
says okay you don't have to so yeah and
the next page you have something that
kind of sort of gets to that so I'll
touch that on the next page ah
so on the next page
what we see is
um on the left a pie chart of the
recommended interventions so of the
assessments that we complete
28 of the time we recommended Court
involvement typically what's happening
there is that the offense was you know
fairly serious that you have a family
and or a youth who's not willing to
engage voluntarily in services and you
know we're really saying you need to
have a court involved in this to make
sure that this family and this youth are
engaged in the process but I think
what's really exciting is 72 percent of
the time we're identifying that these
are kids and families that could have
their needs met in the community through
a service without having to go to court
at all
um and of those 11 going to local
diversion programs so I don't know how
familiar folks are here with the version
I know uh representative DeSimone can
tell us all about it at some point
um but those are those are programs that
um work with kids around restorative
justice models to help them
um understand kind of the harm that they
caused work with victims to try to to
heal the harm that they caused and get
them engaged in some type of pro-social
work
um about 13 are being recommended for
higher level Behavioral Health Care like
Fast Forward which is you know not
surprising to me but that you know is
indicative that there's a lot of kids
who show up in the juvenile justice
system that have unmet Behavioral Health
needs and another 14 that are showing up
with a need for some type of outpatient
therapeutic care so not like uh not a
high level fast forward intervention but
just like Outpatient Therapy
um those are probably that's probably
one of the biggest gaps we're seeing in
the system though in terms of getting
access so we're having kids who are
identifying with that level of need but
having the hardest time getting kids
enrolled in outpatient therapy because
of just access issues with clinicians
the next chart I think gets to kind of
sort of what the chair was asking about
which is once we make our
recommendations
law enforcement actually does not have
to agree with us they can file
regardless of what we recommend right
that's the way the law was written that
they have their own discretion but 94 of
the time they're agreeing with us
they're they're following the path that
we set forward and early data is that
you know the outcomes are pretty good
here you know of all the kids that are
going through this process it's a
relative handful that are coming back
for a second time within the first you
know six months or so of going through
this process so we're really excited
about what we're seeing that being said
it's all still very early right we don't
even have a full year behind us
and I'll pause on that in case there's
anything
representative Perez
thank you Mr chairman I do have a
question everything sounds perfect
in the real world right
but any of these programs or any of this
taken in consideration uh people
background religion language because a
lot of people we come in from different
backgrounds and a lot a lot of times
when we talk about children and
younger Generations
it's difficult to them to feel
comfortable to speak with someone
especially with different religious
background or language
do you guys have
a training uh people in the department
they they know how to handle situations
where a young or children feel unsafe to
be speaking because you know
the backgrounds and and beliefs yeah
yeah so two parts that I think yes there
are there are services and trainings for
all of that but I also think that a lot
more that can be done right so there are
trainings around you know Dei trainings
trainings around and actually the Kansas
assessment actually has specific
sections around understanding religious
cultural differences and things like
that
um and we have what's called a language
Bank you know but the truth is you know
that engaging with families often is
really really hard when you have a third
party in the middle of it right and it's
it's much better if you actually have
somebody who's actually shares the same
culture and history and traditions as
the folks you're working with and that's
an area where I think we probably still
need to do much much better
um
very quickly uh is my background
um sometimes it's difficult for big
things especially like a child a young
person
to speak up because uh
immigration studies sometimes temporary
immigration status
the debt Department
protect the studies of the victims
because a lot of times and victims they
are afraid to speak up because uh legal
status right yeah I mean I think the
with children in particular they're
stronger there are pretty strong Federal
Protections in terms of them being able
to actually gain legal status through
um uh the what is it the
I'm not remembering the the acronym
right now but there are two different
pathways through which if a young person
is a victim of child abuse or neglect
that they can actually gain legal status
through our through our system and
through our processes so for children
those prime those protections do exist I
think at the same time that doesn't mean
that they actually understand right a
child who's a victim in the community
probably doesn't understand that those
protections exist and probably doesn't
understand that those those fears can be
can be alleviated and met right so I
think there's definitely work to be done
in terms of helping people understand
that we actually can can help navigate
those things for them thank you yeah
stipulating that having
someone
who shares religious ethnic linguistic
background is a good thing
can you speak to the level of
intentionality in recruiting and hiring
yeah I mean honestly in child protection
right now the workforce issues are such
that it's you know we need we need
everybody that we can get
so um you know we're we're hiring as
rapidly and quickly as we can and we
intentionally recruit for all types of
groups of folks and everywhere that we
possibly can but we're short of Staff
right so it's it's you know it's you
can't be too we can't be too selective
in a moment that we're you know just
trying to maintain enough staff to to
manage reasonable caseloads the medical
center I'm part-time CEO of shares this
problem too yeah did I see a hand uh
I know I'm getting there representative
Raymond thanks it's a lot it's a lot of
names to start out with the first day um
thank you Mr ribsom and and thank you
chairman for calling on me
um on the the topic of Staffing
um I know from watching the news and
um just having my fingers in a lot of
areas in the community that
um it's still very challenging for
people to access mental health treatment
for children is there
um an advantage that families get from
being involved with your agency now is
there a way like are you able to cut
some of the times I know we have kids
sitting in ERS for weeks to months we
have you know I think the last time I
was looking to help someone get into
mental health counseling for a teenager
that wasn't suicidal it was like a four
month wait
um are you seeing the same thing we are
yeah yeah we're seeing the same thing I
mean so the the system of care for for
mental health it's the we access child
protection and Juvenile Justice access
the same exact system that the public at
large accesses we don't have a separate
special system or separate special
access right so
kids involved in our system are also
um you know also have the same
challenges in terms of getting getting
access and wait lists
um
you know we've seen I think a lot of you
know improvement over the past few years
in terms of having some of these things
available right having fast forward
available for the first time I Can Only
Imagine
how awful things would be today if we
didn't have that available you know
having rapid response available I can
only imagine how awful it would be if we
didn't have that available that being
said I think you know what we've seen
over the past you know in the post
coveted period was the identification of
mental health needs just Skyrocket
um you know I think that's something
that when when
um Rebecca Ross from children's
behavioral health comes she can go more
into that but I've seen some data that
she's presented which has just been you
know jaw dropping in terms of folks
identifying mental health needs and
Behavioral Health needs of their
children you know going from you know
very low levels to you know 90 of
adolescents identifying as having some
type of mental health need
um so the I think the the dynamic has
shifted in a way that is
that's that's daunting
representative Grossman
got it thank you Mr chairman
um have you also noticed
the pandemic affecting the mental health
needs of our children I mean I know just
in my area and being a mom of three
teenagers I've seen how it directly
affected them
yeah I'm sure I mean I you know it's
hard for me to point to exactly what the
driver of all of this is but certainly
the timing is such that you know we saw
coming out of that pandemic and out of
isolation and everything else the the
mental health needs of young people just
absolutely Skyrocket and but you know
when we talked about children in
emergency departments I think one of the
things that was fascinating to the
department is that historically the kids
who would show up into the emergency
departments were already known to the
system and the kids that were showing up
in emergency departments post-pandemic
were kids that were not known to the
system so you had a lot of kind of new
entries into the system of you know
intensive mental health needs in a way
that you know nobody had experienced
before so you know I'm not somebody who
can figure out exactly what the driver
is but the timing is certainly there
foreign
[Laughter]
pretty much blunt I grew up with a
family from New York and Massachusetts
so I can keep up with you um
is there anything that like we can do to
help you when it comes to like the
mental health especially when it comes
to youth we're seeing a lot of Youth
especially My Generation generation
after me with anxiety depression and
they're entering into the workforce and
into the world with all these things and
especially when they're in that in the
system
and they're being like passed over for
someone that's suicidal or whatever and
just because they haven't talked to
someone about how they feel because they
don't know how to because they come from
families where it's just like oh a
therapist you can't talk to a therapist
because therapists are quacks you know
and all that stigma and
um is there anything that we can well
and I think I think if we go if you just
go back to that one page right and and
we'll see 13 14 of the kids that are
getting assessed through this Juvenile
Justice assessment process are showing
up as requiring some type of Outpatient
Treatment and as I said that's actually
the thing of everything on that wheel
that we're having the hardest time
accessing is outpatient care I think you
know that is a place where we need to
put a lot of attention on how do we how
do we prop that up and expand that and
support access to outpatient care for
young people what's really interesting I
don't have this data in here but it's
it's the most fascinating data I'm
seeing from this Juvenile Justice work
is the cans assessment so it looks at
all different domains of child and
family need right and
um we get two interesting data points we
get the data point from law enforcement
as to what brought the child to our
attention and overwhelmingly that's some
type of violence typically a more minor
violence or a simple assault a fight
after school something like that is what
brings them in but then when you do the
cans assessment which goes deeper the
presenting issues have very little to do
with violence and have a lot to do with
depression and anxiety
right so the driving factors behind
those those incidents that are bringing
law enforcement in are actually
depression and anxiety which often are
things that you deal with more through
an outpatient and then perhaps with some
medication you know in partnership with
your PCP so I think that's really the
space where I most see the need
um you know we've built out this this
higher intensity fast forward program
and while there's room to grow there and
we still have need there you know we're
on a trajectory with that but this this
outpatient space is a space where I
really feel like we have the the
greatest need
okay
representative Moulton
hi thank you chairman
um
so if the outpatient realm is the
hardest that you're accessing then the
only way to solve that is to get more
outpatient providers which is not an
easy task because they have to be
certified in their field before they can
offer therapy so
I'm just wondering if there's
an alternative pathway or if one can be
developed if there's not one already
where they can have some sort of
intervention with a provider that's not
necessarily
a counselor but so and I'm not I'm not
trying to undermine you know mental
health it's very important but if
there's some other way for them to get
what they need without having to see a
counselor that's going to be the only
way we can solve this until we get more
counselors in the field right
yeah and I'm not 100 sure the answer to
that right I'm not the expert in that
piece of it but I do think those are the
types of solutions that we need to start
talking about and thinking about right
and I again I think you know we'll have
Rebecca Ross here it's a good thing to
talk to our partners at Nami about it's
a good thing to talk to our licensing
folks about right I think those are
those are the types of conversations
that would be helpful
yeah yeah
before Mr ribson resumes I'm going to be
living in a few minutes and
representative long if you would take
the chair and adjourn about 12 10 I know
there's
we're running over but you're going to
be invited back
um so we'll pick up for it and I would
say yeah I'd say to the committee please
be here at one we're going to start
um hearings on bills so
all right thank you so if we move on to
the next page page eight
so we talked about the work we're doing
on the Juvenile Justice side to try to
shift more Upstream identify families
needs we're trying to do something very
similar on the child protection side and
that's what what we're talking about on
page eight here so create Pathways to
identify needs and pro actively
guide children youth and families to
appropriate support before child and
Community safety are jeopardized a
couple different ways we've gone about
doing this one was doing some work on
our intake so intake is our hotline
right somebody suspects abuse or neglect
they're calling the hotline historically
up until just a couple years ago if you
called that hotline with a concern for
abuse or neglect you got one of two
answers it was yes we're screening this
in and we're going to investigate or no
we're not screening this in
and that was the entirety of it now much
of what we get calls about is not things
like sexual abuse and physical abuse
much of what we get calls about are
things like neglect driven by poverty
driven by
unmet mental health needs driven by
unmet substance use disorders right so
there's a lot that comes into that
hotline that doesn't really reach the
threshold of a child abuse or neglect
investigation but for which there is
still a real need that needs to be
addressed and so the one of the first
things we try to do is shift the way
that our hotline practice worked to
offer a third option there so when
somebody calls the hotline now
most frequent callers you know we get
calls from all different types of people
but the most frequent are teachers
that's who calls us more than anybody
else
um so now if Teacher Calls and they're
calling and saying look Johnny is not
coming to school with a coat in the
winter that really is not a child abuse
investigation but that is a kid that
needs a coat that is a kid that needs to
be directed to how to get a coat
um so what will happen now is a hotline
caller will then refer that teacher and
say look here's your local Family
Resource Center this is how you can help
that kid access the code that they need
so they come to school with with their
coat
um
that's felt pretty good unfortunately we
actually haven't seen the numbers of
families showing up in Family Resource
Centers grow as a result of that change
in our practice so it was nice that we
were able to offer that intervention but
we actually haven't seen any real impact
from it the call volumes remain the same
Our Family Resource Centers didn't
actually report more people showing up
so that you know it meant it wasn't
particularly effective we're still doing
it but we wanted to do something else so
now we're working on two other things
big picture thing which probably will be
live sometime this this time next year
is something called a community Response
Guide
what that's going to be it's a web-based
tool
and it's available for and we're on page
eight I see people flipping around just
in case sorry it's a web-based tool for
folks who are callers to the hotline to
guide them through a decision tree
around should you be calling the hotline
or is there some other resource that's
good to help this family so imagine if
you're the teacher and you're worried
about sex abuse and you go to this tool
and you start typing in it's going to
say call the hotline stop messing around
on the internet and just call but if you
go into this and you type in that you're
worried about you know the child's
presenting without a code or they showed
up without
um they they're showing up without you
know breakfast or something like that in
the morning it'll do two different
things it'll guide you through some
questions to probe a little bit deeper
as to what's actually going on there it
doesn't take identifying information
there's nothing like that it's just
scenario based and then at the end it'll
do a couple things it'll say one you
know here's information for say your
local Family Resource Center your local
food pantry whatever it is so that you
teacher can help connect that family to
the resource or if you're not
comfortable with that here's a phone
number for somebody to call to come
Community Navigator so that's a new RFP
that we put out this past summer that
we're going to have going live this
spring and a community Navigator is a
person who can then pick up the phone
and talk to that teacher or whomever the
caller is walk them through how do you
engage with that family to get them the
support that they need this is the types
of supports they need and if that
teacher or whomever says I'm not
comfortable doing that that's not my
role then they say okay we'll call the
Family ourselves
and they'll reach out to the family and
get the family the help that they need
the Hope being that that intervention
will actually connect those people to
the resources in a way that when we just
had our hotline doing it wasn't actually
effective and the goal being that if we
get more of these kids and families the
things that they need early that we
won't have them coming back into the
system for deeper needs later on
any questions on that before I move on
guide representative yes
um
this is more than a question uh it's an
observation
um
what I
hear than what I see is
um a lot of families
especially when it comes to asking for
assistant for food assistance or a
winter jacket or things like that
um a lot of people right now they're
working through a temp agencies okay so
during the holidays from Thanksgiving
until New Year's the superior that
people work in temp agencies that don't
get paid for holidays
and they only get paid for a certain
amount of hours
my concern is that a lot of families
don't go through the these agencies to
ask for help because a lot of agencies
they ask for I pay stuff
in a lot of this family they only go
through this heart shift or hard time
during the holidays
they they don't have enough money to
provide food or they don't have enough
money to provide things for the kids
and they make it difficult for a lot of
people to qualify
I just wonder if you know if we can find
a waste
to help children and families that the
families don't feel like they have to
bring a Bible completely Bible of
documents just in order to get a jacket
or a piece of bread for the kids because
a lot of times that's what is happening
and I keep hearing from people in my own
Community that's the problem that they
give them 15 to 20 pages to fill that up
just for a piece of jacket or piece of
bread that the people just walk away
because they don't feel like that they
have you know the time or that you know
they need for a longer period of time so
they just give up
interesting yeah I mean I think the
so like the Family Resource Centers for
example you know they don't they don't
typically require anything like that for
folks to come in and you know but they
also don't have as robust of a support
service as say like a a TANF benefit
where you do have to actually go through
the whole qualification process and meet
meet Federal requirements right I think
it's it varies differently depending on
the type of program the type of
assistance that you're seeking I've
never actually heard of you know the
food pantries though being you know that
that intense in terms of being able to
provide
um you know food assistance to folks
that type of food assistance but SNAP
benefits for example which is a federal
program so I think a lot of it comes
down to you know are you talking about
the federal programs which have some
pretty rigorous requirements or you know
some of these more local things where
you're providing an actual concrete good
you know like you know an actual actual
food or actual coat where they tend to
be a little more you know a little you
know more flexible with some of that
stuff but
um it is a you know the the barrier
issue
our real challenge I think the stigma is
a real challenge too in terms of folks
you know being afraid
um to come forward and you know identify
that they actually need help
thank you
this next page page nine
so one of the areas where we've we've
had some growth over the past few years
but there's probably a need for
continued support is with our Family
Resource Centers that I've mentioned a
few times so a couple years ago we
contracted with our Family Resource
Centers to set up what's called kinship
navigation programs the kinship
navigation programs are programs for
folks who are caring for kin kin being
kind of anybody who um any child who has
a connection to you right so it could be
your grandchild that's the most common
scenario right grandparents caring for
grandchild could be niece and nephew but
could also be the person you know if
you're the child you grew up calling
somebody auntie and they're not really
related to you but they could be caring
for you right and that's okay it could
be a member of your faith community it
could be a neighbor it could be a coach
whomever right the idea being that
there's all types of people in in in the
lives of families that are important in
that step up in times of needs and we
need to be able to support those folks
the kinship Navigator programs are
relatively new to New Hampshire
um and what they do is they provide kind
of support groups they help guide those
relatives or caregivers through
accessing benefit services such as
relative caregivers are currently
eligible for the TANF benefits to help
support the the costs of raising those
kids
help them guide them through the legal
process if they need to obtain
guardianship of a child or something
like that and I think one of the most
key important pieces helping guide them
through kind of the the emotional
challenges of changing the Dynamics and
roles within a family right if you're a
grandparent and suddenly you're caring
for your grandchild and maybe your Gran
your own child is maybe angry at you
over this scenario they feel you know
you might have a scenario where that
child is happy that you're helping him
out you also get a scenario where that
child's angry at you for interfering in
their lives or you know it's it can be
really really tough for that parent or
that grandparent to manage so they
provide a lot of support for that stuff
as well and those are relatively new
they've been around here for was it
maybe three years now yeah piloted in
January 2020 Statewide September of
2020. and what you see on the right here
is Our Family Resource Centers and the
number of new families that they're
actually encountering every single
quarter
and every single quarter our family
resource center is around the state are
encountering close to a thousand eight
hundred nine hundred new families that's
new families walking into Family
Resource Centers every quarter by
program type which is huge
and you know I think just goes to speak
to the amount of need out there and
these Family Resource Centers really are
you know they're really operating on
kind of a shoestring budget funded
largely by philanthropy and fundraising
and
um you know not really fully funded by
the state they're getting kind of a
little bit of money from us to kind of
help keep themselves afloat but uh but
not you know much of their much of their
need being being met by private
fundraising and things like that and
they really are a key part of the social
service system that we expect to meet
the needs of our young folks and our and
their families
any questions on this
representative Moulton
so do you I'm kind of a little confused
about this graph so it's new families
each quarter but are the old ones still
being served as well or do you kind of
start and finish them within one quarter
oh no they could still be they could
still be being served this was just this
was just representative of how many
families were walking in new every
single quarter to show that there's you
know new demand to constantly coming
into these places
so basically your workload is
exponential then
essentially
enjoy that before I forget
um there was a list of acronyms that we
received last term I'm wondering if uh
Miss Dwyer could receive a list of
acronyms that the dcyf has yes would be
helpful did we put that together or who
put that together last time
okay
I believe we got it from Rebecca Ross
okay yeah it was a yeah I think it was a
DHHS wide acronym list we can do that
okay great thank you we could get that
out thanks
um and I don't know how long you want to
go I'll I'll keep going until you tell
me you're ready to another five minutes
okay great so that'll get us kind of
through this first part and then we'll
get into the we can get into the deeper
stuff at another
conversation
next page page 10
. so this is talking about
community-based voluntary services so
dcyf as I said before historically we
could only offer a service to a family
once we got court involved and once a
court ordered service came into place we
changed the law for that shortly after I
arrived back in 20 maybe 19
2018 maybe we changed the law for that
so that we could offer voluntary
services to families but the reality was
is that we didn't have the workforce to
offer too many voluntary services to
families because we just right there's a
lot of need out there and we just don't
have the staff to meet all of that so
what we designed instead was this idea
of community-based voluntary Services
where we contracted with a couple
entities to work with families who were
identified as high risk of coming back
to the child protection system but for
whom there was not active abuse or
neglect requiring a current court case
so every single time Child Protection
does an assessment we do two things we
do an assessment to see was there abuse
or neglect as defined by New Hampshire
law yes or no and and two we do an
assessment as to is there what's the
risk in this household How likely is it
that this household is going to come
back to our attention based on what's
happening in this household
the first question was there abuse
neglect we only answer that question yes
about eight percent of the time believe
it or not it's very rare you know New
Hampshire is a pretty high threshold for
what qualifies as abuse or neglect
but the second question of risk about a
third of our families come back is high
risk so that meant and we've been doing
this for 15 20 years so that meant that
all that time that we could only offer
services when you had a court order
which was only when you could
substantiate abuse or neglect that our
staff were going out there and they were
identifying
one-third of our families as being high
risk of coming back and they weren't
able to offer them any service even
though we knew and we were assessing
that they were likely to come back to us
so what community-based voluntary
Services is is whenever we have an
assessment that comes back as high risk
those families are offered to this
voluntary intervention to work with a
community-based program
in most of the state Waypoint holds the
contract up in the North Country the
Family Resource Center at Gorham holds
the contract and the way that that works
is during our assessment process we'll
connect those families to these
providers these providers that Outreach
to them and they try to get the family
to agree to come in work with them they
do some planning with the family they
use a model called solution-based
casework where they kind of identify
what the family's needs are how to build
up natural supports that's the idea of
building your community around your
family to help support your family
and help make sure that they're
connected to whatever other resources
they need in their Community to be
successful and hopefully prevent that
family from coming back to us a second
time you know historically what we see
is families cycling through the system
over and over and over again so this is
pretty exciting that this is finally
live
um you know started March of 2021
serving families last year served 861
families this year served a little over
a thousand families
the next
slide
yes oh sorry chair hi I'm Lori law I'm
so sorry no that's right
um I apologize I just wanted to um
clarify I'm just wondering if you have a
partnership with the school districts um
when these families are identified like
this and um does the school are they
made aware of the family so that they
can also step in
so
child abuse neglect is is a difficult
area because there's a lot of
confidentiality around what we can and
can't share and if a call comes in from
a school then there's information that
can be shared back but unless the call
comes from the school other than us
doing an investigation and speaking to
the school and trying to elicit
information is not a whole lot of
information that gets shared back
directly with the school district
where there where the schools can get
involved though is kind of in the
service provision aspect of it so not in
the investigation part but the service
piece right so when we talked earlier
about something like fast forward and
you have kind of your High Fidelity rap
team the school should be sitting at
that table if we have a child in foster
care for example and we're doing
planning the school should be sitting at
that table for a program on
community-based voluntary Services
ideally the school is engaged at that
table so it's really there's a little
bit of confusion around kind of how and
when those connections happen it's a
little bit trickier around the
investigation space but but more
comfortable and common around that kind
of service provision space
okay that makes sense yeah that's what I
was wondering because
um not that you would have to share a
lot but if you had high risk children
and you just say we have children at
risk and they don't need the extra
background or are they referred to a
special education are they referred as
other things ruled out for those yeah
for that family is what I was wondering
yep yep thank you
all right um next slide page 11 is just
talking about Staffing our child
protection Workforce so when
um I first got here five years ago case
loads for child protection assessment
workers were in the 60s
um shortly before that they were in the
90s
um the standard nationally you know
should be not that Most states meet this
but should be 12. that's the case load
that we should be expecting staff to
manage
we're currently we've been pretty good
good being able to hold in kind of like
the mid to high teens for the past
couple years
um but we haven't been able to kind of
get down to that that 12th number that
our goal is a couple years ago when when
lots of Investments were made for this
purpose we were we did a deep analysis
as to how many staff we actually needed
to get to that threshold number of 12
and we actually I think do have the
right number of staff on paper
to get to that but we haven't been able
to fill enough positions to actually get
to that number
um where you know
I think today we're actually doing a
little better than we have been for the
past few months
um you know we really had a bit of a
downslide I think between
late last winter through about October
November and then we kind of saw our
hiring be able to pick up again you know
I've heard different things about
changes in the in kind of Workforce
hiring and kind of Health and Human
Services hiring in general that was
certainly we've seen on our side so I'm
hopeful that we'll start to see that
pick up but we certainly saw a pretty
tough go of um of hiring Workforce kind
of in the post-covet environment both in
the child protection sphere and um in
sysc the uh the secured facility yeah
thank you
um I'm not going to speak to what it was
when I left in 2017
um but I'm curious if these numbers are
for um all staff or if it's just uh or
if foster care Staffing is a little bit
better because I know in the past it was
like 20ish for foster care and the goal
is 12-ish yeah this is this is
assessment staff
um family service so is what we call the
the foster care Staffing the goal for
that's actually 10 and that hovers more
around the 15 number okay thank you oh
yeah both of them are higher than we
want to be but they're they're better
than they used to be I I believe it
questions
Joe we're gonna call it what's there uh
we're gonna recess for lunch and come
back we have a one o'clock hearing all
right thank you very thank you everybody
foreign
acknowledge the presence of the the
chairman of Finance
open the hearing on House Bill 124 and
act relative to Temporary alimony Prime
sponsors representative
the Simone would you present your bill
please
did the prime sponsor designate someone
to do it for her
with the vice chair introduced the bill
please
from there
thank you Mr chairman I'll let you do is
Hospital 124 relative to Temporary
alimony
well done
while we have already sped forward to
the pink cards
chair recognizes
The Honorable gentleman from Atkinson
I believe it is Jay Markell
and there's two rules here number one
you gotta set
and number two
guess guess what's next
that's three number two is you gotta
turn the mic on
and you do that by yeah and you know
you've done it because the red light
comes on and then you got to speak right
into it okay okay so do one you've done
two and keep three in mind thank you
okay thank you
okay well good morning uh Mr chairman
Vice chair and members of the committee
my name is Jay Markell I'm a practicing
family law attorney in New Hampshire and
have been admitted closer oh okay thank
you and have been admitted to the New
Hampshire bar since 1998.
um I was also involved in drafting some
family law legislation working with
representative Deb D Simone and others
over the last few years and one of them
has been involvement with alimony
particularly the alimony statute which
ultimately a different version became
law back around 2019 while the law does
a number of good things there are some
flaws in it that need to be corrected
and actually they're more in the nature
of housekeeping details what brings us
and one of them here I think is foreign
section of RSA
what it does is that it defines
temporary alimony and by the way I can
give some handouts here for distribution
which I think may help clarify should I
just leave them here or to pass I would
suggest you walk them to my honorable
committee researcher who will pass them
around okay thank you there are two sets
of statutes there one is uh 458 19 and
458 19a
um okay so what this bill does is that
it looks at 458
okay I just want to get the definition
section here 458 19 which is being
passed around and I've put a check mark
it's on page two and it deals with 458
um
458 19
section 14 where it defines temporary
alimony as being the periodic support
payments two are on behalf of a spouse
while a case is pending and ending on
the effective date of divorce or legal
separation or annulment and such and
that such alimony shall not be counted
towards the subject or either the
formula or duration limits of 458 1983
unless the court finds that the
temporary alimony was of unusually long
duration now the
problem here is is that the entire
intent of the statute isn't initially
passed was designed to order to predict
predictability into alimony statutes in
other words before
it's still pretty much going to the
casino and you may not know what you get
but at least you have guidelines to work
with the guy and what this bill does is
that it simply brings temporary alimony
of whatever duration to be paid okay in
Conformity with
um
uh with can in Conformity with
um 458
19a2 a which says that they'll both be
subject to the same regulations now
currently that means the uh lesser of
the reasonable need of the payee or it
would mean a maximum of 23 percent as
the as the law stands currently excuse
me Council I'm going to ask you to stop
for a minute I've got this stack of
papers there's no Staples anywhere and
there's numbers of pages that look
different to each other so I'm a bit at
a loss as to how many pages I get okay
well you get a total of okay I'm sorry
you get a total of one two
I can give you my copies if you like
well I'd like about 16 of them okay well
then I can staple them uh if need be
um what it is is that it's 458 19a and
it has its and it's a total of four
pages and 458
19 which has a total of two pages okay
so the it starts with the letter
parentheses G that's the first page
um
the first page is uh are you looking at
458 19a or 458 19. 458 19a okay 19a
begins with the letter one it says the
court May order term alimony upon
payment
upon agreement of the party right now I
am totally lost on this this this is
okay needs to be redone okay well the um
the essence of the bill is simply this
it brings it into Conformity and um I'm
happy to provide stapled copies that I
have here
to give the uh chairperson
or I will
if you would give your copy to my
committee researcher granted this is not
research but she she's multitaskable and
take this watch of things here and
purloin a stapler from somewhere
he would do us a great favor
thank you okay okay sorry about that Mr
chairman okay the the point of it is is
that it really just makes one small
correction and what it says is is that
it just brings it into Conformity the
idea of bringing it into Conformity is
is that unless you have immediate
irreparable harm uh facing a payee uh
for some reason that isn't foreseeable
that it simply puts alimony in the same
category temporary alimony in this in
the same duration limits as term alimony
uh and by the way that doesn't paint
anybody into a corner the idea here is
is that if you have some extraordinary
circumstance that wasn't foreseeable and
that you need to vary from that formula
you can okay just tell us what it is and
why it's irony and why you need it and
why this is going to be irreparable harm
if it's not granted
um now the other question that typically
you might run into is uh well
um
if we have that what about other bills
if the order of alimony simply isn't of
enough to be able to compensate somebody
for bills well if you have that kind of
income disparity there is absolutely
nothing precluding a court ordering that
in addition to the required alimony
amount that a disparity of income person
who's making a lot of money can be
ordered to pay
bills in addition to the temporary
alimony so that means nobody would be
conceivably left destitute nobody would
ever receive basically a quote
inadequate alimony award because alimony
is only one piece of a divorce puzzle
um and that's really it very Simply Now
the problem so one of the questions that
might come up is why do we need this
well the problem is is that you can get
all kinds of insane things going on in
court and it undermines the entire
intent of the statute which is
predictability uh uh you know I had one
case where uh the alimony Seeker trumped
up a bunch of a number of things
ultimately we had to go through
Discovery the court ended up referring
the matter to the county attorney's
office for perjury and fraud and a bunch
of other things that's the kind of abuse
that it opens the door to
um so that's really it in a nutshell and
if there's any questions I'm happy to
answer them
thank you
the chair recognizes representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you Mr Markle uh the uh so this
also adds a court show
make written finding support in its
artists also so that's that in addition
to what's currently in there now that's
correct right so the rest of the alimony
statute stays intact all this is really
is just correcting an oversight okay so
uh follow up on me follow up thank you
uh so I had wrote a note that it first
requires Court finding but that doesn't
change from the what's originally in
statute no it doesn't change it in other
words the the rest of the statute stays
the same okay what it just says is the
Court's simply going to make written
findings for its order and you know
that's not a burden on the court and
what it does is it just makes everything
more predictable and actually it helps
for both sides uh a potential payee can
go if the potential payee is represented
by Council I'm sorry this is in the way
here so I okay there's a potential payee
if represented by Council can go in and
say okay well you can ask for temporary
alimony this is what it would be but if
you feel this is inadequate we can go in
and we can ask that other bills be paid
in addition to alimony so uh we can get
the mortgage paid we can get the
utilities paid we can get the this paid
we can get that paid as long as there's
an ability to pay
um now from the payees now from the
potential payor's side the benefits to
both Council and pro se are that you can
say to yourself okay well this is what I
would be expected to pay if the court
finds that the rest of the factors are
there
so in other words it just kind of evens
things out makes it simpler and easier
to understand so you don't get some of
the kind of
frankly crazed pleadings and sometimes
unpredictable orders that that can
result from this kind of thing
thank you sure
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman
um so this bill it says has been in
committees ever since 2015. has there
been harm in the fact that it hasn't
been passed for almost eight years well
I don't think this particular bill has
been in committee since 2015 because I
was working on alimony reform starting
in 2015 and we had a number of
iterations on alimony bills I had
provided a couple of them the couple of
the solutions that I had provided were
later incorporated into what became the
alimony Reform Act in 2019. so I don't
recall this temporary uh thing being in
there I can't specifically address what
that would have been
follow-up follow-up
um according to this that they that they
passed out now some sometimes it's gone
over to committees
um to study
whether or not it was needed but
regardless
um has there been harm
in not passing it
um well the answer is the answer is I've
personally seen it yeah I've seen people
get orders that they either couldn't pay
uh our firm has seen orders that they
couldn't pay and unfortunately it's
subject to judicial discretion so
they're largely unreviewable as long as
there is a quote objective basis for the
findings and rulings the courts make on
appeal uh and personally is I'm I can
only cite I'm I'm going to cite right
now only one case that came out of the
Nashua court that I had where the payee
went in and made a number of
representations as to what their income
was
as to the exigency of circumstances that
would have required an alimony order
we had to go through the extensive
Discovery process to find out that not
only had this person perjured themselves
that they had lied repeatedly under oath
and on interrogatories had concealed
information and ultimately the court
made a referral to the county attorney's
office now and this isn't the kind of
thing that you would like to see on a
regular basis that's only one glaring
example uh uh so in other words so what
is the harm that it prevents it it
prevents a lot of harm and what it says
is is that and it's just basically
fairer to both parties now on the other
side
if you've got immediate irreparable harm
while you economic harm that is lead
your case
just argue bring us the facts and
figures that say there should be a
variance from this order
or variance from this statute and if you
can do that
you know that's fine that's what courts
are all about
any further questions from the committee
representative Raymond
uh thank you chairman and thank you uh
I'm curious about how this change would
stop the situation that you gave as an
example because I don't see how this
language
um would have stopped that particular
individual from committing all of that
fraud I mean it seems to me that we
already have under
um 458 19a for
um an allowance for the court adjusting
formula amounts
um if the court requires that Justice
requires an adjustment so I guess I'm
I'm curious about how this would
prohibit that example from happening it
would cut down on it nothing is perfect
uh but the point of it is is that when
people see that uh I think there would
be less likely to do it and there would
be better Arguments for it and you know
nothing is perfect this just cuts down
on it and it also does something that
the for the current statute doesn't do
which is ADD predictability which is
what it's supposed to do
did I if I if if there if I haven't
answered your question because
follow up
um no
no representative Bickford
thank you Mr chair man
um
so it sounds like the formula is too
rigid
and confined and we need this to relief
valve well what it does is that actually
this actually adds predictability in
other words the whole point of the
alimony statute was to add
predictability and to give all both
parties in the courts guidelines and
guidance from the legislature as to how
the alimony statute ought to work
um so what this does is that this
corrects well I think is frankly an
error in the statute and
um and says okay look this is what it is
going in okay this is what you can
expect now human nature being what it is
in the human existence being what it is
I go back to what I said before if you
have some kind of immediate irreparable
economic harm
tell us what it is
and uh and be prepared to verify it just
don't make it as an offer of proof and
uh offer of proof means your honor if my
client were to testify this is what
they'd say okay uh just bring it
and then the court can have a basis to
rule on as it is now you know the whole
point of the alimony statute was to turn
this from a wild west shoot amount into
something that we would be able to have
some order and be able to work from in
guidance and I remember a number of the
judges when these alimony statutes were
being worked we're looking for guidance
and thought it was a pretty good idea so
that's where it goes thank you sure
thank you for your testimony thank you
chair recognizes the prime sponsor of
the bill Deborah D Simone
the vice chair kindly introduced the
bill for you and now deep simony it is
Italian we pronounce every letter not to
be confused with French where we skip
some of them right
German we'll get back to you
yeah my my ethnic background is Scots in
English and we won't even bothered to go
there I um
I I only need about a minute I
appreciate
um
the vice chair for introducing the bill
I apologize to the committee for my
tardiness it's not the way I roll
um I appreciate
um
Mr Markell for his comments and the
reason that I sponsored this bill is
simple
constituents
and judges have made it known that the
alimony process is not quite what it
should be and this helps it along it's
not a 100 percent fix but it gets it
forward
thank you
any questions for the primary sponsor
saying none thank you and come on back
up thank you Mr chairman I'll stay out
here because the next bill
will be mine as well
As You Wish thank you Mr chairman
sure recognizes Mary and I'm reading
this is is this Krueger
ah yes
representing the New Hampshire legal
assistance people
thank you
um Mr chair and members of the committee
I'm Mary Krueger I'm an attorney at New
Hampshire legal assistance we're a
non-profit Statewide Law Firm providing
free civil legal services to people in
poverty to help them meet their basic
needs including issues like housing
Income Maintenance and we also operate
at domestic violence advocacy project
where we represent clients victims and
survivors of domestic abuse in a civil
protection order hearings and also
divorce and parenting cases
and
um I come today in opposition of this
um change to the alimony law
and there's a few reasons for that that
I can speak to First is
um I was part of what we called
informally an alimony working group back
in I think we assembled in the summer of
2018 if I recall
which was headed up by a woman named
Honey Hastings who unfortunately has
passed away
um and uh she was really the leader of
our group of a variety of different
family law attorneys
um mediators and others who help people
with divorce law in New Hampshire
and we really spent you know we did
probably 10 different meetings over a
summer to help draft what is currently
the alimony law which is made up of RSA
45819 and RSA 458 19 Dash lowercase a
um the the purpose of that law was to
establish a formula which is currently
in place that was amended
um slightly due to changes in federal
tax law but that's been in place
um
for the last couple of years and this
change here would just change the
definition of temporary alimony
um
so the the difference is there's term
alimony which is the alimony that would
be put in place on a final basis after a
final hearing and when a final decree is
issued for the divorce
um temporary alimony is what's put in
place
um while the divorce is still pending
um in the court system
um temporary hearings are generally
scheduled pretty early it's it if
there's no mediation or if mediation
fails the temporary hearing is what the
court scheduled in order to put
temporary orders in place like use in
possession of a marital home
payment of certain bills child support
if there's children and things of that
nature
and temporary orders are usually made
before there's any been been any formal
Discovery where people
would be exchanging a number of
documents about income and assets and
ownership of various you know cars and
real estate and all of the you know
stocks and bonds and whatever other
things that may be part of the marriage
and
um so often it would be very difficult
to
um
have a formula apply at that time
because
um the formula is based on the two
parties gross income and then it's 23 of
that gross income and if there's other
kinds of payments over property that
hasn't been divided yet and people don't
understand all of the
value of all of those things and and
what kinds of payments might need to be
made
that formula could be confiscatory on
one or the other party
and therefore when we worked as a group
of family law practitioners
um you know thought about that and
really
knew that having the court to be able to
not be bound by a formula at that time
just didn't make sense because
ultimately it needs to decide all of the
other distribution of property and debt
and
once it's able to do that then the the
formula can apply because you assume
that they've been able to you know
figure out the disposition of all of
those other things whereas it's really
too early to do so at the temporary
stage
and then I would just say that the way
that this is written I've read it over a
few different times I understand the
purpose now having heard from Mr Markell
um to explain that I'm not sure that the
language that I'm reading actually
accomplishes what it is
um that I think uh the intent is for
what I've just heard which is to have
the formula be the default at the
temporary stage
um and and allow the judge to Veer off
from that if there would be economic
harm I mean that burden would be on the
person who is the recipient of the
alimony payment but this language here
um
says such alimony shall not be subject
to the duration limits under RSA
45819-a and the formula limit under RSA
19-a2 unless and then then so it's
saying it's not subject which is that
that's the current law is that it's not
subject to the the formula the duration
limits and the formula limits currently
that that's what the law says and then
this says unless the person
um who's seeking the temporary alimony
um and the court finds that irreparable
economic harm would result If the
percentage formula were applied which
presumes that it is being applied so
it's it it's not the language If This
Were passed it would confuse the courts
it would confuse attorneys I'm confused
by it so I'm not sure that
the way it's written is accomplishing
what I'm hearing is the change which
fundamentally I would argue is not the
right change to make
thank you
any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you counselor thank
you
the chair calls Vivian
Gerard is it
I guess so
did I get the name right yes good
afternoon members of the board
um
I just wanted to voice my opinion on
this because I was affected terribly by
alimony during my divorce case as many
of you know when you're dealing with
divorce in alimony there's many factors
that need to be looked at here
in my case and this is all I can use
here is in my case I had a child that
had a disability
I had left my employment after 15 years
to raise my my daughter I was married
for 19 years
and based on our family I put my ex
through school he got his engineering
degree
and he made more money than I did and
based on my daughter getting kicked out
of school or preschools at three four
years old we had to do something during
our divorce not only did my employment
suffer they told me I was underemployed
even though we decided before we filed
for divorce to start up a family-owned
business
and
um in order to
file for divorce they did Issue me a
temporary alimony
but I feel that not all of the factors
were looked at based on the current law
so I agree with Mr Martel that a lot of
this stuff
um really needs to be looked at there
needs to be a lot of housekeeping
involved here and it really needs to be
looked at based on the duration of the
marriage
what your factors are if you have a
child a disability
and in my case I decide what we as a
couple decided that we were going to
start up our own business at the house
so I could remain employed have my own
income base right after we we um
purchased the property where I was going
to perform my business
um unfortunately my ex was not in the
marriage anymore he decided to move on
just because he decided to move on
did not stop the opportunity that I
started to get my business off the
ground
my parents have moved in I had my
children in the school system
my business started to really pick up
and in order to keep the house I did
need the alimony I did need child
support and because of
my situation on the judge used so much
discretion and she found any way
possible to vary from
the law I think that we really need to
have more detail
um Crossroads as to all right how long
were you married for were you married
over 10 years were you under 10 years do
you have children how old are they do
they have disability like you need to
know more about a family rather than a
judge
ruling on your life not knowing any of
the background any of the details and
the fact that in my case I had a five
and a seven-year-old child
I lived in the marital house because
that's where my business was if I gave
up my house I would have been unemployed
and living under a bridge in a cardboard
box
what's the best way to do it here keep
me in the house with the children and
keep them in the school system for the
benefit of the children or is it better
to leave me homeless and unemployed
and then to boot um the judge used again
too much discussion I have a book about
this thick
um where she did not take the interest
of the children in any way shape and
form I lost all the property even the
kids beds the bureaus and everything
else
I lost my 401k I lost everything so
doing the the Equitable divisions are
not working so if you have in my case
would have been nice to have some kind
of unemployment I'm sorry um uh alimony
because I I wasn't eligible for
unemployment I wasn't eligible for State
services and it took so long for me to
get into the system to Beyond Services
which I should not have been if I was
married to somebody that made 150 000 a
year I should not be struggling to put
food on my table pay my bills keep my
children in their their doctor's
appointments because I couldn't even
afford the co-pays and the fact that
there's so many different problems
based on the court system in the in the
deviations that they make you give them
too much deviation they don't know which
way to go they can make up any
decision that they want and then you
become a taxpayer burden so I guess I
just want to make sure that you guys
understand that and and these type of
systems if there's fault in
on the breakdown of the marriage if
there's
unequal property Division if there's all
these things that are going on within
the court case you got to think about
that parent that's trying to raise those
children in that household
so I I guess I would just look at the
way that it's written and support that
part of it are you willing to take
questions if there are any from the
committee absolutely are there any from
the committee
saying none thank you for your story it
gives a personal
note to
uh our hearing today sorry I took my
earbuds out because my phone is ringing
that's quite all right and actually if
people do want to read up on it more
it's the Silva V Silva case thank you so
much thank you
and I have no more pink cards that have
been handed in so I will close the
hearing on House Bill 124
my guess is that we're not ready to move
forward on this we would like to ponder
it for the next week or two or not so a
straw poll how many of you would like to
move to exec this bill right now
all right
how many of you would like to wait
that's
very decisive thank you
and now where are we we are on open the
hearing on House Bill 85 the chair has
flown in at no expense whatever uh
representative D Simone from the front
of the room to present her bill 85
relative to anti-nuptial agreements
anti-a-n-t-e meaning before not a n t i
meaning against
85.
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee my name is Deborah DeSimone
I represent Atkinson Rockingham 18.
I brought this bill before you because
uh
quite a while ago
um we in this state
started to allow
same gender marriages
but the law continued to say him her
he she
this bill brings for that I bring forth
will change that to
be more gender-neutral
and that's what we need to do that's all
it is it's a very simple housekeeping
bill
thank you thank you
the last time I used the word
housekeeping in committee 20 minutes
later they rewrote the bill but I think
you can get away on this one
maybe so maybe no we'll see
would you take questions absolutely
questions from the committee if any it's
pretty straightforward yes
representative Raymond I I apologize
because I'm new do we have standard
gender neutral language that the state
has been using in bills thus far no okay
do we have suggestions for dental
nutrition is it just going to be they
them
I believe that it states that in the
bill
oh two people I apologize it would be
two people okay as opposed to they them
or whatever
yeah thank you those acronyms
continually
seem to change evolved yes
thank you so I wanted to be neutral
thank you representative long
thank you Mr chairman
um
do you see an issue with adding the
adult to adult people or would that be
complicated
considering the fact that at this point
um
marriages can take place at
unfortunately the age of 16 who are they
are not don't leave early this afternoon
you're right
I at this time 16 year olds are not
adults
so I at this time would prefer not to
make that change at this time okay thank
you well I get where you're going
thank you for introducing your bill to
us I see no further questions
unless you'd like to say something no
thank you Mr chairman you're welcome
and we bring back uh I was going to say
old friend I mean friend of some
duration
um attorney Markel
thank you Mr chairman
um
it is I suppose I guess one would say a
housekeeping Bill
uh it needs to it simply needs to bring
the statute the reason the language
change is necessary is is that it simply
needs to bring the statute up to date
with the marriage laws as they exist in
the state of New Hampshire
um one of the questions was my initial
involvement with this actually came
quite by accident uh last year I was
asked to do an opinion letter on the
validity and enforceability of an
antenuptial agreement for the state of
South Carolina
for a court for a litigant in a state in
the state of South Carolina
and in research and it's important
because the anti-nuptial agreement by by
the both parties said that in the event
of a dispute the laws of New Hampshire
shall control the outcome of any dispute
arising in uh North Carolina in as a
result of this antenopsial agreement
so I looked at the statute and I
realized I think it was created in 1981
long before same-sex marriage became
lawful in this state which it did by
operation of law by passing the
appropriate statutes which I think is we
all know also became the law of the land
in 2015 under the United States Supreme
Court
so I looked at the statute and I
realized wait a minute there's a problem
here because if it says a man and a
woman now what happens if you have
same-sex couples who are married and who
are in the similar circumstance and it
only says a man and a woman
so then all of a sudden imagine the
problem of South Carolina judge is going
to have if all of a sudden the same
thing comes up and you have two same-sex
couples and they're going to have to
interpret it under New Hampshire law and
they're going to see wait a minute you
guys you can't do it because you Bound
by New Hampshire law and New Hampshire
law if you have two same-sex couples
whatever the merits and whatever the
outcome is going to be is going to be
bound by the statute and since they have
to give full faith and credit
as a general proposition to another
State's acts which is what New Hampshire
does
okay with out of with antenuptial
agreements it would only make sense that
with a simple word change we bring the
statute up to date and just say two
persons and in for example with
representative Long's position which no
good point adult well once again you
know it's two persons marry and so
whatever the two persons are going to be
it's going to depend on the laws of that
state as to whether they can they can
they can marry or not okay so that's how
it more likely would be interpreted and
that might be buttressed by the uniform
marriage recognition act okay which
which helps that if there's any
questions I'm happy to take them
seeing none thank you counselor thank
you and I have no more pink cards so I
will close the hearing on House Bill 85
and in consultation with my vice chair
as per our new house rules I am now
opening the executive session on House
Bill 85 would somebody care to make a
motion
the chair recognizes representative D
Simone
cherish you don't mind could you tease
us along the way
she will make a motion on ought to pass
and representative Moulton I will second
that most well done to the committee
your first second
I will second that as ought to pass all
righty any discussion
we're having an exact session
195. yep
yep okay so we got two clerks now
waiting
any further discussion
when the clerk is ready the clerk may
call the role on House Bill 85 and act
relative to ante nuptial agreements the
motion is ought to pass as moved by
representative D Simone and seconded by
representative Moulton
Mr chairman Pearson yes
representative long
yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative
yes
it is 16 to zero before the gavel drops
anybody can change a vote you get a one
last little round I'm not advocating for
it I'm just telling you what you may do
hearing no one the results are it is it
is past 16 to zero any objection to it
going on to the consent calendar
thank you there is no objection to
consent calendar would you also like to
write the uh what do we call that thing
now report the blurb yeah
you will write the committee report yes
yes thank you very much
this closes the exact session on House
Bill 85 and now
I am opening the hearing on House Bill
200.
flown in from across the hall
representative Nara Upham from the great
health and human services Committee of
blessed memory to present her bill which
is 200 and you have a surprise for us
the amendment I have a surprise for you
and Amendment if I do
YouTube
should be around yeah
um
does everyone have representative Nutter
upham's amendment to her own bill
you know if an amendment comes in from
somebody else there's a different order
but since this is her Amendment this is
really the bill she'd like us to look at
and you you told me over lunch that you
thought it better worded what your
intent is
it's coming is coming
please take a look at and I'll give you
an extra one for your folder uh please
take a look at house bill
200 Amendment
001h 1010 Amendment
2023-0010 hotel that is the amendment
it is coming
foreign
to us okay thank you good afternoon
everyone
I'm Francis Nutter Upham
I'm a psychotherapist I'm from Hillsboro
8 which is Nashua
um I've had experience working in
private practice
inpatient psychiatric hospitals
Outreach clinics
regular clinics where the clients come
into your office
um I have worked with some abused
children over the years I've only been
to court once with one of those children
so I'm looking at this from
a therapist viewpoint but I realize you
are child and family law
so
um this bill
likes the purpose of it is to give
parents who have for some reason come
before family courts
and their child uh has shown some kind
of signs that perhaps they need to be
evaluated
that the parents
have the choice to choose an evaluator
therapist
licensed person whatever under their own
health insurance plan
instead of there could be cases where
the court just appointed
a list of therapists that they had and
the family had to pay out of pocket for
that and I I don't know how expensive
these evaluations could be but a regular
therapy session is upwards of a hundred
and fifty dollars and I think as
legislators we're trying to fix problems
and make things easier for our Citizens
We're not trying to add
ugly burden to a family that's already
experiencing difficulties
some of the other
things that I learned about
um who who appoints right now therapists
or evaluators and I read that um
Guardian ad litems gals
who I thought naively were volunteer
like Casa workers and they are not
apparently
uh they are paid for by one parent or
the other and so I'm I
calling into question perhaps the the
fairness
or their
non-partiality of recommending a
therapist I mean we all get comfortable
with people we know but I think in this
case I it's time to in empower the
parents to be able to go to their ensure
I mean if any of you have had um
probably experience with picking you
know medical doctors or counselors you
call up your insurance or you go to your
their website and you say you know who's
an expert in bereavement who's an expert
in whatever maybe you can look at their
faces and and choose a counselor that
way it's also
I was thinking time and distant
constraints in New Hampshire that if
someone was appointed a counselor that
was an hour and a half drive away one
that was somebody in their town
on their insurance plan that they could
use that would be causing undue hardship
so that's the gist of my bill it's just
giving the parents the choice to use
a counselor under their insurance plan
and there's a Proviso that's added in
um about if the parents can't agree
to choose one that then the court would
step in
so I you know I
I think some of us can't imagine how
content contentious a divorce could be
fortunately I haven't had to see too
much of that but anyway so
um that's the bill and I'd be happy to
take any questions
representative Moulton
that was my hope but but then I realized
that it could be just one parent paying
for it which
yes thank you in a perfect world that's
the deal okay thank you
oh gross one better
thank you she was born in Germany I know
I won't ask my question in German
um
I could only give you one or two word
answer back in German
so if
just to confirm that if they do not
agree if the two parties involved are
not in agreement and then it's going
back to the court to decide
they do have the court will then have to
pick someone yes in network yes thank
you thank you for your question
foreign
representative Raymond
thank you chairman so the current
language says that
um the court needs to
um do
um do consideration to finding one in
network do we know that if there's a
problem with finding providers in
network I guess is my question and then
the second part of the question is what
about for those families who have New
Hampshire Healthy Families or Medicaid
for whom there is a significant lack of
providers available right now
that is an excellent question I don't
have an answer to
thank you I just know that of course
some therapists will work on a sliding
scale they'll take your income into uh
you know they'll take a look at it and
decide that well okay you could pay
fifty dollars for a session instead of
the usual 150. so I think with with this
bill this way if a family didn't have an
insurance
but but that is something maybe you guys
can figure out how to add on to this to
have people covered who don't have
insurance but at least this would give
someone
um the opening to try and find someone
who would work for a sliding scale in a
in a more affordable
um thank you therapy session thank you
for your question
representative do you think that we
should uh
perhaps put language in your Amendment
regarding what would happen if the
parents have no insurance or there was
no one in network because I I could see
in a restrictive way the court shall
choose a participating provider in the
party's health insurance carrier Network
begs the question that the parents have
that so how is the court now instructed
if uh there's no one in network or if
the parents do not have insurance I I
would want that in here somewhere I
think that would be an excellent
addition to this and I don't know and
I'm not sure if anyone here knows what
does the court currently do when someone
has no insurance
well
it's in here
I don't have that it was a Christmas
present I didn't need clothes
new cribbage board you know
um my suggestion would be before we exec
this bill you could find out from those
who know it and perhaps when we do go to
execut there'd be an amendment in
instead of 200 that we could consider
yes I would be happy to do that okay uh
representative Perez
thank you Mr chairman my question is
what happened in one of the parents I
don't agree it has restrainted order
foreign
again I'm familiar with the therapy side
of things so
the
what do you mean that exactly um because
sometimes I mean the child can't see
this parent because of the restraining
order oh you know they can agree with
you know what therapists or who's paying
for a whole second uh
um
who's going to make the decision about
the therapist because it's a restraining
order but that pairing is the one who's
paying or the the other parent cannot
afford it how did that gonna work well I
think um with the Proviso if there's a a
sorry I gotta find the line
line seven of your Amendment
uh in the event that abuse has been made
and I would assume that if we have a
restraining order that would sort of
imply that
um that then the court would decide
so okay it's probably hard to
put wording in for every possible
scenario but I think that Loosely covers
that
thank you for your question
representative representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman um just to comment
on what representative Perez was saying
there's usually language in there that
says who is going to make the
decisions about medical
um in the in the temporary orders or in
the the divorce decree uh in the event
that there's a restraining order and
somebody else can't
okay thank you
speaking
as a therapist
now you've got to go talk to the lawyers
yes not to cancel out your good work
here as a therapist but just to make
sure that the court understands and
doesn't find themselves in a conundrum
yes I I think that the coverage what do
we do with people without insurance
which someday I hope we never have to
say unless and until yeah and also those
those cases where the parents may be
unable to agree because one of them has
by court order been put out of the
picture
you know I'd run this I'd run this by a
lawyer or two to see what they come up
with okay because it's a good bill yeah
thank you you're welcome anybody else Mr
chairman you'll give me a heads well
I'll get back to you before you schedule
an exec yes think about the 24th
this is a month
[Laughter]
no last month
a few people um who want to uh speak to
this bill and uh put you in the front
row there as an expert in case you're
the one that can answer the question
that they raise thank you very much
you're welcome glad you're here
chair calls I believe it's Dana Albrecht
did I get the name right
uh yes uh Dana Albrecht for the record
and rep Grossman can probably pronounce
it better than I can I'll burst yes
so for the record uh Dana Albrecht
Nashua New Hampshire
uh I'm the father of four wonderful
children
uh first uh very brief background on my
own case and then uh three points in
support of the bill
uh also is a preliminary matter if I
could respectfully request the chair to
tell us the name and title of your
Christmas present
New Hampshire juvenile laws was one of
them
the other one was law Essentials of
family law and it has a practice LSAT
test in there which I aced so now I'm
being sent uh things from law schools
asking me to apply in my spare time
perfect uh we could all come on up and
take a look at it afterwards yeah yeah
great
uh so by way background I've had my
adventures in the New Hampshire judicial
branch some of you might have read about
those in the union leader uh but uh I
have a multi-state uh uh
diversity of citizenship case
uh where New Hampshire has decided over
the uh objection of both parties that
Michigan should now have jurisdiction
concerning court orders that require
counseling occur in California and
nobody lives in California so we're
having fun dealing with that right now
uh but moving on to the bill
uh sort of three points in support
uh first off
uh without getting into the weeds
uh I think we have a crisis in the
judicial branch right now
uh we've had a number of outgoing uh
judicial officers under leave under
judicial misconduct and we've had a
whole lot more uh incoming and
inexperienced judges
um
and I understand we've even gotten to
where we're closing the judicial branch
uh twice a month for two hours
a day uh in the morning to do in-service
training so again you know lots of new
incoming people anything we can do to
help them out I think would be a good
thing and I think this uh bill would do
that
uh so that's sort of Point number one
uh
Point number two
is I think this bill uh
furthers the provisions of our state
constitution
uh
so
uh you know a lot of the stuff in the
constitution is short and sweet and then
you expound upon that in statute and
hopefully that all comports and I think
it does here and especially when you
know judges have a little more detail in
statute uh that certainly helps them out
but uh in particular uh parenting rights
are protected under article two of the
state constitution
uh and so
uh if you look at the text you know on
the one hand the language bold in
section three
you know parents have a right to choose
a counselor on the one hand I think they
already do pursue into the state
constitution on the other hand you know
that's going to be hard for a judge to
figure out so let's just put it in the
statute where it's nice and clean and
unambiguous
um
I think uh this also sort of goes toward
furthering what's been called the spirit
of equality that pervades the entire
state constitution
uh again you know therapist before going
to the lawyers now
uh but I think we have a disparity of
outcome
uh across the state in various family
court cases you might get the I mean
it's kind of the luck on the draw
depending on which court you wind up in
which judge you get uh just a lot of
variables there
and if you have a little more detail
written into the statute of you know how
a judge particularly a new and
experienced one
uh is supposed to handle something then
I think that can be helpful
um
so I think again
uh if you go back historically there's a
sort of an ancient uh Supreme Court
opinion that's still cited today which
is a state V Pinoy or 65 NH 113 from
1889.
uh but it's one of those Classics that
people still keep citing so most
recently uh an opinion of the justices
uh 144 nh374
1999 and Vermont also deferred to that
uh for equal protection Provisions in
marriage but bottom line is it talks
about a spirit of equality that pervades
the State Constitution and back then it
was about having sort of different
outcomes in different areas of the state
and we're going to ask you to kind of
wrap it up because we've got some folks
before you okay excuse me uh I think I'm
actually done mostly so just coming back
to that is
what I think this goes to address is a
lack of
quality throughout the states and
disparity of outcomes
and that we're seeing now that's sort of
In conflict with
you know case law and why not fix it at
the trial court instead of litigated all
the way up you know the Appellate food
chain and with that uh any questions do
we have any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you Mr chair the chair recognizes
Sebastian Fuentes Senora Fuentes
hey we are trying to become multilingual
in this committee Good Start thank you
sir welcome
good afternoon everybody uh thank you
for allowing me to speak today uh my
name is Sebastian Fuentes I'm the
movement politics director for our
organization called rights and democracy
uh but I'm here to speak in a capacity
of a parent that had to deal with with
this exact issue a few years ago
um we went to a divorce about about
eight years now ago and um you know it's
trying to as you know when you go
through a divorce is it can be a bumpy
Rocky situation and sometimes kind of
dangerous for for either parent or the
child
um at that point uh the the court at
that time uh appointed me of letting
that light him that I had no idea who
that was uh
no the mother of my daughter uh didn't
know who that was as well uh we have to
come out with money we kind of were
forced to pay a specific amount of money
it was about a thousand dollars at the
time but as you know when you go through
a divorce
um everything changes your financial
situation changes your living status
changes so uh it becomes a problem so at
that time I have to sell some of my
belongings to be able to pay for that
Garden online in my half of the of the
amount so um I wish I wish this piece of
legislation was was a law back then
because it would help me be able to find
somebody more affordable uh somebody
that uh local close to the community
where I was living because you know
living in a North Country there's not
that many uh so it was it was it made it
hard for us to to be able to to get to
that process and because I didn't have
the money at the time uh you know I have
to delay the process a little bit so the
the you know the the printing coming out
with a printing plan and the divorce
settlement everything it took a little
bit longer just because we didn't have
the means the financial means to pay for
that I don't know item so I'm just here
to uh you know to speak on support of
this bill so hopefully you guys will
consider it thank you
any questions for senior Fuentes
Senora Perez in Spanish or English
I'm gonna do both here we go with
subtitles please
um I'm gonna do it in Spanish first is
um
I'm asking if he believed that these
legislation would help him at that point
that he had a hard time monetary a hard
time and the parents would benefit with
this bill will pass
oh absolutely yes see see uh no
absolutely that would have helped me
tremendously back then and not just me
you know it will help also the mother of
my daughter as well trying to be fair
here in the discussion you know both
both sides
we need the assistance and that's just
my reality I know that's the reality of
many many Granite theaters
any other questions
okay muchas gracias thank you
chair recognizes Vivian Gerard
hi chair and members of the chair
um I just want to speak with you um not
that I was very prepared for this today
but you are asking about how this
affected people and I was actually one
of those people and when I could not
afford
um certain appointments for my daughter
because she had a disability and based
on our situation my ex was the one that
made all the money and I was the one
that was caring for the children mostly
um in my situation where he had the
insurance and I had to pay the co-pays I
got to a certain situation where I could
not pay those co-pays and he was
supposed to pick up the other portion of
that and he did not and what happened in
my situation was anything outside of a
certain Network they did not cover or
they covered 80 percent or whatever the
percentage was
so unfortunately
he did not feel obligated to pay these
medical expenses and because I was the
parent that took them to the
appointments and this is where we have a
big gap in the law people
um whoever takes that child to the
doctors is the one that bears the
financial burden I'm going to interrupt
you here and I'm not quite sure how this
relates to the bill before us uh it may
relate to bills we're having later well
but this has to do with the right to
choose the counselor or the right to be
evaluated that's where I'm going with
this all right so in my situation
because I could not afford these things
and he carried the insurance he was
demanding who these people went to and
unfortunately because I was the one that
was taking them it fell on me
financially so it hit my credit I went
into very bad credit standing because of
his lack of payment
then it got to the point that I had to
go on State Insurance because I could
not afford the people that he picked so
as a person of my stature I was the
housewife so to speak and the
stay-at-home mom and self-employed
business
so I did not have the rights that most
people do
in a relationship it's not going into an
even ground whoever carries a financial
amount and in this case he did he made
150 000 versus what I made which was
closer to like 70. it's all income based
but it took me a while to get to where I
am because it was a brand new business
but it so getting back to where you're
trying to go here is Whoever has that
Financial
Drive is the one that gets to pick and
they don't care the burden that is put
on the other parent a lot of the times
and the judges don't care
which way they go they're just trying to
find a happy medium on that insurance
but they don't see that the financial
burden really falls on the parent that
brings this child to the doctors so
that's just what I wanted to leave you
with because I again I wasn't prepared
for this but I wanted you to know from
my point of view that this is what Hit
me hard and put me in a financial
situation where I could not recover from
now you said you weren't prepared but
you sure do ad-lib well I lived this
life since 2014 and it was not an easy
life thank you would you take some
questions if there are any anybody
questions
representative Raymond
um sorry I just wanted to know at the
end of all that do you think that this
language would have helped your
situation
um it hasn't entered yet so absolutely
if I was in that situation at the very
beginning I would not have fallen into
collections I would not have fallen into
the situation that I'm in financially in
this burden representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman
um you're absolutely right because
co-pays are are due at the time of
service so I've got a kind of be a
question so that's what I'm getting
would you believe that then you say what
you want to say okay
but what I'm getting at is is there a
possibility in certain situations that
you and your ex or or a person and their
ex could make an agreement as I'm the
one that's taking the kid to the
doctor's appointment because it is
easier due to my schedule could you help
pay the co-pay because I think that's
the only way someone would be able to
get out of your type of situation would
you believe would you believe I believe
that is not going to be correct the
reason being is my ex and I could not
make an agreement to the very beginning
we had to have the judges intervene on
every aspect of it and because certain
situations took higher priority
my attorney kept saying we cannot bring
this to court yet they're already
looking at too many problems so if this
was an automatic part of the law where
it automatically says both parties are
responsible or in
a portion of it
is you know say 40 60 or whatever the
case may be
I think that would help somebody of a
lower Financial
income because it's not fair walking in
you're not at certain levels you're not
equal and that's where the the law falls
short is they assume everybody's equal
and treated fairly and they're not good
thank you
and thank you for your testimony thank
you chair recognizes The Honorable
Melbourne now if he's French it's Morin
if he's Irish or English it's Moran
Moran English or Irish both
of course mutt that's not a mutt that's
a hybrid well there's a lot in my family
uh French too at some point
then it could be Moran yeah well I think
it's Moran I have to double check now I
might have been pronouncing get back to
me
in my life okay thank you and you're
from Vandal lost Services Wonder yes
wonderless therapeutic services uh hello
uh former colleagues um my name is Noble
Moran Jr I'm a licensed independent
clinical social worker I also own one or
less therapeutic services in Nashville
we serve about 700 people in the greater
Nashville region through our outpatient
counseling division we also serve over
500 in our forensic Social Service
division which includes Domestic
Relations
um I hear today because
um I'll show you a note Wanderlust is in
New Hampshire's greatest City Nashua
um
chair recognizes representative Nutter
upman for an outburst
so
representative uh Nutter Upham reached
out to me about this particular matter
and I uh was and so agreeable that I
want to come here and take time out of
my day to express how wonderful this
bill would be I'm also a guardian litem
down in Massachusetts and we deal with
Guardian leaders up here in New
Hampshire as well so there are often
times where the guardian Elena will
recommend a particular therapist that's
at a network I'm sure many of you know
if you're familiar with mental health in
the state of New Hampshire that many
therapists choose not to enter uh health
insurance Network plans and they charge
a significant amount up to 150 200 an
hour our private rates 200 an hour but
that's just someone's making a
substantial amount of money two hundred
thousand dollars or more a year
um
in this case we do get a lot of families
that are referred to us because we take
every major Insurance including Medicaid
and at our agency so we do a lot of
family counseling family systems
counseling high conflict resolution
counseling which is um
very common in these type of cases where
the parents are essentially using the
child as a pawn uh to for their own
means and and we do a lot of that
Services here uh there is
stories I could tell you a story after
Story of speaking to clients who have
been trying to find a therapist who's
been told to go this one that when they
aren't in network and they're they want
to charge them 150 an hour and we can
all be honest the probate and the family
court system uh in any state especially
here in New Hampshire and the state that
I'm a gal in Massachusetts it's everyone
wants to make sure they get paid if
someone has the financial ability to do
so attorneys need to get paid therapists
want to get paid Garden Millennials want
to get paid I think this bill helps
insurance companies kick in their fair
share of it to reduce the burden on the
actual parents and the children who are
going through a very difficult time in
their lives I think this would be a
great uh way to limit the burden the
financial impacts over the very costly
system that is the family court
and I could answer some of the questions
that were asked earlier but if you have
any specific questions for me feel free
you served in the house yes last session
yeah I thought so yeah that was me that
was you rep long on the and we were also
an executive committee I believe too for
the county you can vouch for him I I
don't know if he'll vouch for me but
he'll acknowledge that I was here
any questions
yeah representative Vlog having time for
him yes chairman uh do you do you um
do you take clients that are court
ordered with no insurance so we haven't
had clients court order with no
insurance there have been situations
where clients have been court ordered to
our agency and we've helped them apply
for Medicaid uh and then they get on
Medicaid and then we can take New
Hampshire Healthy Families well since uh
or amerihealth there are times that very
very rarely will you find a child a
child under 18 without health insurance
in the state and if they don't have
health insurance and they their family
has the mean lacks the means they're
easily I'm talking about very easily
qualified for Medicaid in this state
okay and I'll follow follow-up uh with
respect to co-pays
is what we've heard earlier is that if
I'm the one bringing the uh bringing the
child I'm doing the copay even though my
spouse is responsible for the payment is
there a delineation from that so
typically
[Music]
if two parents bring a child they're
both financially responsible unless
there's a court order and this is my
agency's policies other agencies might
have different policies if there's a
court order that says one parent is
financially responsible for the co-pays
and one's responsible for providing the
insurance then yes then we would have to
seek the co-pays from that uh one parent
that the court has ordered responsible
there's no court order they're both
responsible for their child's finances
if they don't pay in my case we bring
them a small claims court and we resolve
it there but we don't send anything to
collections thank you
great thank you for your testimony thank
you Mr chairman
this concludes the hearing on House Bill
200 and
representative NADA Upham is going to go
talk to the lawyers and you'll be back
and we'll probably exec this in two
weeks
thank you
Mr chairman
hi hi
um
I
would make a motion to exec it now
because I don't necessarily see it as a
high priority to make sure we get
further language into the amendment
about
uh families that don't
um have insurance if what the person who
just testified says uh happens rarely
you don't have standing to make that
motion okay that is solely in the
discretion of the chair now in
consultation with the vice chair okay
but nice thought great
see you in two weeks thank you no no see
you now okay now
um I asked my wife this this whole
question of since we're not in West
Virginia you shouldn't get married when
you're 12 what would be the appropriate
age and remember she's a physician and
her answer was for women probably 21 and
for men Maybe 40.
and uh that assumes she's met a lot of
mature 40 year old men yes
foreign
we're getting there every every couple
of years where where we're bumping it up
um
all right where's the gavel here is the
gavel we are now opening House Bill 34
FN
raising again the marriage age this time
to 18 and flown over from the the side
over here is
foreign
okay this is one of my two deaf ears
this is the other one actually
put some data
hello Mr chair uh and members of the
committee my name is Cassandra Leck I
represent Stratford for Barrington and
Stratford
I'm here today to introduce HB 34fn
which raises the marriage age from 16 to
18.
the reason for this bill is I have
received throughout my journey of
fighting this
so many letters of survivors
of people in support
and I wanted to give you the data that
follows all of those stories that I've
listed in my testimony
which is
that
it is a lifelong impact on people's
lives
they will always be affected by the
child marriage it lasts Generations
and
it never ends until someone decides to
stop it
it is
coincides with domestic violence human
trafficking and so much more
and I
have also
heard a lot of the opposition for this
is teen pregnancy and the military
we are at the second lowest
teen pregnancy rates in the US
Massachusetts is the lowest
uh as for the military
the military is
against those that are using their men
and women that are serving as benefits
as using their benefits towards their
advantage and they since DNA has been
involved and especially with crime and
everything they have used it to
determine paternity and it will give the
benefits to that child and they can now
designate
benefits towards spouses towards anyone
that they decide they want to receive
those benefits
um so
part of my journey I have found child
marriage was in my family
I knew of my grandmother who was married
at 16 to a man in the military
he was abusive towards her verbally and
said this is how many women I have been
with these are why they are so much
better than you are
and she had a child from that marriage
she decided enough was enough she can't
deal with that verbal attack every
single day every time he came back from
Pearl Harbor
and decided to take her child and go
back from Florida up to Massachusetts
where she is originally from
and then looking further I found that my
great-grandmother on my mom's side on my
dad's side sorry was married at 16 to a
49 year old man who abused her verbally
and in front of their children who
thought that was okay for a marriage to
be like that
and that was passed down from generation
to generation until someone decided to
end that and say enough is enough which
happens to be my parents
they decided no more of this drug
alcohol any of that is enough is enough
we don't want our child Me growing up
with this
um
child brides are neither physically nor
emotionally ready to become wives and
mothers
they face more risks of experience
stayed during conflict dangerous
complications in pregnancy and
childbirth they can contract HIV and
AIDS
and suffer from domestic violence
with little access to education and
economic opportunities saying their
families are more likely to live in
poverty and the generations after them
stay in poverty
going to college is still very still
very rare occurrence
in our family
and most of my relatives work in
low-paying jobs and
live right along the federal poverty
line
child marriage is Insidious and affects
Generations it's not just sticking with
that one girl in that one marriage
some people feel like 16 70 year old
children know what love is and fully
understand that they are potentially
understand what they know what they're
getting themselves into the reality is
they themselves
do not know what the situations they are
getting themselves into are going to be
80 of these marriages end in divorce
and the data is there I actually have my
six inch binder it's in the other room
of all of this and I'm
have it all in my head I'm trying to
digitize it too so that way it's more
portable than a six inch binder
um
some of the testimony some of the
stories that I have been told are
like this one my husband put a dog
collar around my neck and trust me up on
the floor in front of my parents just to
prove to them that he could control me
another one my husband was a monster For
the Love of All That is Holy please do
not let another child go through what I
had to go through
another I was alone my husband deployed
to Germany I had a high risk pregnancy
my parents flew my sister to California
to come and drive me across country so
that my family could help me with the
birth of my son my husband did not see
his son until he was 19 months old they
never bonded
the final one is I was 16 and I wanted
to escape abusive living situation that
I had found myself in I married a sailor
when he came back from his appointment
in Hawaii used to verbally assault me
and tell me all of the other women he
had been with
I didn't know how to get a divorce I
just ran
I as you will no doubt here today many
children find themselves in a marriage
situation that is no longer
problem that they thought
was possible they never thought that
they would be in this situation when
they married
it isn't just the 16 and 17 year old
that are in love that they want to get
married because one of them is pregnant
it's the 16 year old being forced into a
marriage because a 49 year old man
decided I want to marry her and
approached her parents and said I love
your daughter here's some money
if you just let me marry her and due to
States laws and how lacks some of them
are when it comes to marriage
they only needed one parent's permission
and that person gave it and signed the
paperwork and that girl was married and
she was they were abused they were
there's so many different situations
I've heard of women being sent off to
other countries that they don't know the
language they don't speak it they're not
from there but their family is because
that one person knew them
through somewhere
and it's different for each girl but
they all say the same thing that he was
a monster please never take me back into
that situation again please do not bring
another girl into that situation again
that is when I'm asked every single time
and I get approached by strangers who
recognize me and say thank you so much
for ending this for stopping this I do
not want another girl going through what
I had to go through
children do not have the right to marry
because they cannot sign a legal
Contract Marriage is a legal contract
you have to be 18 to sign a contract why
do we allow 16 year olds to sign a legal
contract of marriage when it is 18.
with HB 34fn we are powering children by
ensuring that they wait until they
decide on their own who they want to
marry and why they want to marry and not
let an adult decide for them just
because of money or whatever situation
it is
there is no data that supports child
marriage it is not beneficial to one
child none we do not allow exceptions to
drinking smoking or driving ages we set
those ages based on people who can
engage safely in those activities we
should not do the same with marriage
the likelihood of divorce is 80 percent
for those who marry in mid-adolescence
then drop steadily
delaying marriage until the mid-20s in
reduces one's likelihood of divorce to
30 percent
women who marry age 21 or younger
experience worse mental and physical
health and attain less education and
earn lower wages than those who marry
later
I've also with the
um as lawmakers we have an obligations
to our citizens to lead them on a path
of a success New Hampshire has made sure
that the tools to empower these girls
are available they can access insurance
through New Hampshire Medicaid services
are available through smart part Smart
Start smart programs Community Action
Partnerships can help with their
services of child care home visits and
Supportive Services
girls can get the parental care they
need through a variety of sources
located throughout the state and they
can get rides to the care provider
in 2023 I think that a pregnant teen is
on their own is a ridiculous outdated
notion marriage should not be encouraged
just because it is viewed as a solution
to a problem there are many options for
them out there if they want to keep the
child it is not just
they have to get married
pregnancies exceptions to marriage age
has been used to cover up rape and to
force girls to marry their rapists
marriage license data obtained from
across the U.S so an alarming number of
child rapists recently were handed
marriage licenses instead of prisons and
sensitive sentences sorry about that
marriage
um if New Hampshire creates a pregnancy
exception while other states move on in
the opposite direction New Hampshire can
easily become a destination wedding site
where parents take their daughters who
have been raped to force them into
marriage
this is not
what we want New Hampshire to be known
as just a few months ago in
Massachusetts just passed a law to raise
it to 18 and other states are following
in suit
and I am helping that fight in Vermont
and Connecticut also
um
New Hampshire state department calls
marriage before the 18 the age of 18 a
human rights abuse human rights how
humans have the right to education yet
we know girls who married before age 19
are 50 more likely than an American Girl
Should drop out of school and four times
less likely to complete College
we also have the right to live our lives
free from violence we have the right to
employment freedom of movement and the
right to consensual marriage
child marriage denies many of its
victims those rights
according to the UN convention on the
right child rights a child is defined as
a human being below the age of 18. in
all actions concerning children whether
undertaken by public or private social
welfare institution courts of law
administrative authorities legislative
bodies the best interests of the child
shall be the primary consideration in
child marriage does the opposite of that
and in
the paperwork that I handed out is some
data that I've collected on through
Partnerships that I've worked on
throughout the years
Unchained at last has provided a lot of
the data when it comes to child
marriages in the US the UN has data on
child marriage throughout the world this
is not a small
third world country problem this is a
problem here in the US it's a problem in
England and many countries like us where
we are more developed where we are more
have a better society and better places
where we can take care of our children
so why is still why is child marriage
still a thing here in New Hampshire
thank you
representative D Simone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
can you tell me how many
uh marriages took place in the last five
years in the state of New Hampshire
under the age of 18.
I believe the last count was five and I
believe that's five too many
follow up
thank you for that answer so in that
case uh in your bill you say
um that all marriages contracted by such
persons shall become shall be null and
void so are we to say that whether they
want to stay in the marriage or not
their marriage will be now null and void
because they married under the age
no if that's what this says ma'am so
okay can you help me I do apologize for
that um unfortunately my bill has a lot
of issues with it as you can see um my
none of my uh co-sponsors were listed
um and even though they all signed off
and I signed off yeah
um but OSL is having some startup
problems geez yes
um so I just want all marriages anybody
that future wants anybody that's 16 from
whenever the date is from on that wants
a marriage license has to wait until
they are 18. that's my intent one more
follow-up so would you be amenable to
amend your bill and remove the uh such
persons marriages contracted by such
persons will be null and void would you
be okay about removing that sentence yes
thank you for your input
representative Grossman
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for bringing this forward
and for this important work
um my question is do you know of any
legally binding agreements that someone
below the age of 18 can enter
no they cannot even go onto the Disney
Channel website
without an adult supervision
thank you representative petrigno
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question uh
can a married uh individual under the
age of 18 file for a divorce no they
cannot because they can't contact
contract a lawyer because a lawyer will
not
Allah represent
someone under the age of 18 because they
can't get into a contract because they
are under 18. thank you very much
representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um what is the current age of consent
for sexual activity here in New
Hampshire it is 16. okay 16 or 18
16. okay and my second my yep my
follow-up question is
yes please
okay thank you
um so to follow up how does this
intersect with New Hampshire's recent
passing of a conditional emancipation
procedure through the family court
so with this this does not touch that
this is just dealing with those that are
under the age of six of 18. uh this does
not touch emancipation just because that
gets into a whole money mess of as far
as I know they still they would still
have to be 18 because the
emancipated minor can still not drink
that kills still cannot
drive they can't vote they can't
anything that is set age wise they
cannot do
thank you
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I did a little bit of research and
um you know you're more of an expert on
this than I am so I think you probably
can answer the question but what I found
is that by virtue of becoming married
that minor would be emancipated and
would be able to make
um legal decisions on their behalf
that is not true because they are still
under the age of 18. the only way that
they can become emancipated is if they
have they go through that process and
they are not right away emancipated
right then and there just because they
are married
thank you
chair has a
question
um is it not true that much of what you
said
about
age 8 to 16 is also true at age 18 a 49
year old man Marrying an 18 year old
uh probably someone who marries at 18
will not go to college just like a 16
year old wouldn't that 18 year olds
marrying suffer abuse and so many of the
illustrations you used to my mind did
not did not prove your point it proved
there were bad people doing bad things
and the fact that they're now 18 to have
bad things done to them they're still
bad things even though they're not 16.
um
would you agree that upping it to age 18
really doesn't prevent much of what you
had said
it helps them be able to fight back
against those that have done wrong to
them it allows them to give them time
versus allowing them to have their
voices silenced for years
because even though it is those two
years between 16 and 18. and eight if
you look at a 16 year old and you tell
them you can go to college you can do
this yes I have friends setting that
chose not to go to college that chose to
go into the workforce right away I went
to a CTC school where they offered that
but a 16 year old making that decision
being told what to do versus an 18 year
old being told what to do
is very different because the 16 year
old being told what to do is taught
listen to the mom listen to your dad
listen to this person whereas an 18 year
old
is
when they're told what to do they have a
little bit less incentive to listen to
that person because they are now 18 they
are now an adult they have the right to
make those decisions for themselves
versus a 16 year old has less
of a leg up
than a an adult does it's harder for
them to make those decisions say this is
what I want when a whole bunch of adults
in the rooms is saying no you gotta get
married no you gotta get married
and my follow-up question is I've I'm
sorry I forgot how many 16 to 18 year
old marriages were there last year I
believe
last year I'm not sure
you don't know I don't know okay
representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman isn't it true
though that even though there's not a
large difference between in two years
whether it be 47 to 49 versus 16 to 18
that the human brain is still developing
during the years of 16 to 18 and it
reaches full development at age 25 so
therefore there is a significant
difference
if you would agree
um I believe that there is a significant
difference between 16 to 18 versus 47 to
to 49. yes I do agree with that
representative Bickford
again thank you Mr chairman you're
welcome
um
it was common at one time
that if a girl should get pregnant at 15
16 in fact it was very common when I was
in high school
um against sexual activity is even more
common I believe it's just not the
pregnancy is just common
um but
and and none of those girls would get
married
but who pays for the uh delivery of
children that are not married with the
parents of the girl or
you know where does where does Insurance
play into this um
that sort of thing do you know I am not
a sure about the insurance because each
insurance is so different from each
other and we have so many insurance
companies out there and each one has its
own separate plan when it comes to child
birth and pregnancy and I believe that
there are Services out there that can
help expecting mothers help them find
the help that they need with that okay
thank you
foreign
representative Moulton for one more just
as a follow-up to the Mr representative
Grossman
Bickford okay I'm sorry it's Frau
Grossman and Mr Bickford got it got it
all right most insurance companies well
cover maternity policies so whether
they're under their child their parent
or whether they're under their spouse
maternity is vastly covered
uh if they have an insurance policy
so
we're getting a bit off here
um so thank you I see no more hands up
that means doesn't mean there's no more
hands up but I see no more hands up
thank you so much because we get a lot
of people wanting to come up here most
of them in favor of what you're doing so
thank you so much thank you so much and
the chair recognizes representative
Ellen Reed and right down here it says
CFL that is the Canadian football league
if you were not wanting that but
children and family law you came to the
right place my deepest apologies Mr
chair there's no apology needed I didn't
in fact mean child and family life I
know you did been doing this a little
while
um for the record my name is Ellen Reed
I represent Newmarket and new Fields
um and I am although apparently OLS has
made some mistakes this year and I am
not listed I am as I have always been a
co-sponsor on this bill in fact I would
like to start since so many we have so
many new members this term with the
history of this bill as a freshman in
2017 I was approached right after
election actually representative Reid we
have a printout with all of the history
of the bill in this committee okay but I
I have like a little like personal if
you want to do this you rehearse this
well I didn't really well it's in my
heart rehearsed in my heart Mr chair if
you would permit me
um I was approached by a 16 year old
girl scout saying why are 13 year olds
getting married in New Hampshire and
will you put this in and I said I
absolutely will now as a freshman and a
veteran ended up putting in the bill but
I was a co-sponsor that term and I need
to be clear I don't know um how to put
this uh
speaker Jasper was the speaker
I believe representative Welch was the
chair in other words we were under
Republican control not to be partisan or
anything but just as a matter of fact in
that term that bill bringing the age of
marriage up to 18. it came to Child and
Family Law it went to a subcommittee it
was unanimously passed at 18 out of the
subcommittee in Republican control it
was unanimously passed out of the
committee and on the floor on consent
that year Under full Republican control
it was pulled off of consent
um I do want to at this point because of
the the uh rationale that was given to
pull it off consent uh address a couple
of the questions that were asked that
touched on that the first thing is
Insurance one of the things that was
talked about when it was pulled off
consent was well what about military
um people guys going off to war and and
how would their uh belovs be covered for
the in the child if they weren't married
well in fact insurance does vary
frequently and Military Insurance does
in particular cover partners and also
children so if you are a bylaw if you
have a biological child on the way and
you claim that as your child it doesn't
matter if you're married or not that
that child is covered secondly to answer
more fully that original question
um it's federal law that people have to
be covered under their parents Insurance
until the age of 27. So that obviously
goes past 18.
also
um we could have been at that point the
first state to to make this a law 18
year old marriage just like that in that
but we weren't
um and now some other states have done
it but in that very year that previous
year in my town of Newmarket there was a
13 year old girl who was coerced by her
parents to marry her 17 year old abuser
they later got divorced because he was
abusive but the point is is that this
does happen it's not only kind of the
extreme examples of a predatory older
man but just
parents coercing their child into doing
something that isn't in the child's best
interest
it has been stated before
that a nowhere in the legal universe is
a signature of a minor worth the hill of
beans it's worth repeating that over and
over again because to emancipation the
following year we did put in a bill and
that's where that partial emancipation
comes in but it's worth noting that
emancipation is a legal thing it doesn't
it's not binding to companies so if you
are a car rental company or you are a
landlord you don't have to rent to a 16
year old
you don't
it doesn't matter that they're legally
emancipated and consign something you
you're not forced into renting to them
so just because you
um there's some partial emancipation
that we were able to get the following
year it doesn't actually protect a 16
year old who wants to leave
another piece of legal problem that that
this has caused is when we did and this
is before I ever became a rep actually a
couple years before we passed same-sex
marriage as you know when we passed
same-sex marriage we passed it at 18
which now means that we have a
discriminatory law on the books which we
have already said in our laws we cannot
be discriminatory on the basis of sexual
orientation but it has become de facto
the problem that we have already made
same-sex marriage only legal we are
providing protection for same-sex
couples children up until the age of 18
but we're not providing that same
protection for heterosexual children and
also call them children because they're
still under 18.
um so yes in general if you're under 18
you cannot give consent your signature
doesn't mean anything back to the minds
not developing piece that's a very
important piece not only has your mind
not developed and I would say that
subcommittee where was unanimous under
Republican control that subcommittee I
listened to that entire subcommittee and
they said if we could bring this to 25
and bring everything to 25 we would
because that's when the brain is finally
done developing but since we're not
looking to change the age of voting
smoking drinking and everything else 18
is where they settled because that's
where everything else is set
um but your mind is not developed at 16
but more than that your mind is still
developing and if you are in a romantic
and sexual relationship with who is in
essence your guardian
that messes up your mental development
at the age of 16. and that is why we are
seeing the data that Cassie introduced
increased rates of abuse physical abuse
mental illness poverty substance abuse
lower rates of Education
now it's true of 18 year olds as well of
course but why are we why are we
exacerbating the problem by including 16
and 17 year olds
so yes
um and the fact remains it is still used
to paper over human trafficking there is
a rather notorious example although
there have been multiple ones that I
could talk about but one in Florida
recently where I think it was probably
so famous because it was a pastor in his
40s late 40s who impregnated I believe a
nine-year-old and the parents uh
coerce the child into marrying him at
the age of 10. and that only happened in
the last few years also there are other
notable famous people who have papered
over
these abusive inherently abusive
relationships I mean that in the sense
of
the people that they were in
relationship with were not of
appropriate age and they papered over in
these cases by becoming their Guardians
first which is the situation you get
when you don't have a fully emancipated
person married to somebody who is of age
is they are in effect you're a guardian
in some way you're still going to school
if you're still going to school
potentially and you go on a field trip
who are you going to get to sign your
permission slip your husband
it's a problem so these famous people
who've done this we're going to need to
wrap this up yes Mr chair you're right
I'm very close to being done uh Grover
Cleveland became an official guardian of
the person he eventually married Steve
Tyler became the official guardian of
someone he ended up in a sexual
relationship with and prince prince is
the one that hurts me the most became
the actual official Guardian
um Prince yes he became the official
guardian of a 17 year old I know I it
hurt my it broke my heart to find that
out as well
and so this the point of this is that
parents can and are convinced for a
whole bunch of different reasons to
coerce their child into going and
getting into a marriage whether it's
their poor and a rich person comes into
their lives and say hey I'll give your
child the best that there is to offer or
the child gets pregnant and the the
parents think well maybe it's best that
they are taken care of by somebody else
for whatever reason
a couple other uh on that notorious day
when it was pulled off consent one of
the other arguments was the idea of
religion
there is no major religion that forces a
person to marry someone under the age
under the age of majority a child to
Mary no major religion there are
religions that say that you should not
have sex before marriage but you've kind
of missed the boat on that if they're
already pregnant so you can't just kind
of like retroactively undo the what you
believe to be a sin just because you get
married literally no major religion and
I did minor in religious studies says
that you have to get married
um as a minor and I did mention the same
sex discrimination thing and the
insurance thing so I think I got through
all my notes and I really appreciate
your time questions for the
representative you know the gist of what
you were saying earlier on about how
this Republican committee did this in
the Republic is one of your points that
we all should vote Republican
you know what's funny is that I think
that that might have come across that
way upstairs earlier
an election law committee uh no but I
think the point the real point of that
statement was this should not be
partisan and I think like many many that
illustrates that many things in this
world that we're living in now have
unfortunately become partisan but there
was a time where this was absolutely not
partisan before it became partisan
that's what I thought you meant thank
you thank you Mr chair
the chair recognizes representative
Rosemary rung
thank you Mr chair and I'm going to
stick to my written comments because I
know they're under three minutes
um but I want to thank you all this for
this opportunity to speak to you today
on HB 34. for the record my name is
representative Rosemarie wrong from
Hillsborough 12 which is the town of
Merrimack
versions of this bill as you know have
come before this committee and the prime
sponsor representative Levick has done a
thorough job in presenting the facts and
exposing the damage to girls from child
marriage so I'm not going to repeat any
of that I'm here as a co-sponsor who was
left off the bill
because like you as a legislator I feel
the need for our decisions to reflect
Granite State values
one of the greatest values is individual
freedom
after all our motto is Live Free or Die
it conjures up images of
self-determination and the power of one
person to control their destiny
but if this is really true how can we
tolerate a person even just one
entering into a lifelong commitment
which is solely dependent on the
decisions of others
every other person in New Hampshire can
marry without the parents approval and
without a judge's approval but 16 and 7
year olds can't do that
why because they are too young to make
the decisions for themselves
and if they are too young to make it
themselves then no one should make it
for them and we must pass HP 34 we must
respect that a minor is too young to
make the decision on their own
they're too young to shoulder the burden
and responsibility of marriage 16 and 17
year olds are minors for a reason
to continue their education to complete
their adolescence and to gain life
experiences to shape their goals and
dreams which may or may not result in
the decision to marry
passing HB 34 gives minors the extra
years to develop and self-determine
their future without requiring others to
approve a decision that should solely be
theirs
thank you for your time I think I'm well
under my five minutes but I'd be happy
to answer any questions you have any
questions for representative run
great okay thank you
I'll call uh Sebastian Fuentes
here I am again
good afternoon again Sebastian Fuentes
uh movement politics director of horizon
democracy and I'm here on my capacity of
um a parent you know I have a 17 year
old I have an 11 year old of a
three-year-old who steps on is seven
years old and I have a daughter that is
almost almost two so
um no I'm here to support this bill
because I don't think uh
16 is actually at appropriate age to uh
to to get married you know also I also
for about 20 years I worked in the
hospitality industry and and I I noticed
uh at that age I'm 16 years old
um there's a lot of limitations on how
much work you can do so if you can work
if you can award your 40 hours if you
cannot make money who's going to support
the family you know and if you have a
child who's going to support that child
you know if it happened to me I'm pretty
sure it's going to be
me if that was the case so I'm just here
really quick briefly to just uh support
this bill because I think uh 1617 is not
an appropriate age to to get married
about uh 18 maybe but still it's better
than the 16 years old thank you so much
any questions
thank you thank you
chair recognizes representative Jess
Edwards
[Applause]
uh thank you Mr chair
um I'm just going to stalk you and
follow you around to every committee you
run that's sort of my strategy we both
got reappointed to oversight
so I'm representative Jess Edwards I
represent Rockingham District 31 that's
Auburn candy uh Chester and Deerfield I
put five minutes on the card I may run
just a little long uh in in that and my
rationale for maybe running a little
long is I think I'm on the blue sheet
I'm the only one in favor of marriage
I'm a advocate of the institution
well I'm I'm an advocate for the
institution of marriage and
um I was married uh 41 years we met at a
very tender age the commitment to my
bride never wavered uh so
um I I would like to point out since the
talk about pulling things off of consent
was mentioned earlier by representative
Reed as one of the people that helped
pull that off of consent and convince a
majority of the people on in the house
that it was a bad bill and when it came
back and and on a very rare instance of
a consent pulling something off of
consent getting flipped this this was
kind of a highlight for me because it
was a bad Bill it banned up to the age
of 18.
when it came back
it ended up that um the house a majority
of the house and the Senate agreed to
prohibit marriage at 14 and 15. we kept
the age at 16 17
intentionally I think because we
recognized the science of biology
that our law on consent
happens to be in line with and that when
individuals begin to engage in sexual
Congress a baby is often produced when
that baby is produced as we all know a
tremendous responsibility is created
um there are still a great many people
even at a tender age when pregnant would
want to keep that baby and raise the
baby and for those people I take a look
at their individual right to
self-determination and I don't I don't
want us to skip past this because what
what this bill does is its stereotypes
and blankets and wraps of net around all
people of a particular age demographic
regardless of the individual's desires
and intent and capability and so we so
we go from a state where we say Live
Free or Die to a state where we
eliminate an individual right to follow
up on their natural biology
so I
I would I would point out that
um
we've talked in the past when this bill
has come up about the military
and I I know having been in the military
for 33 years and having had young
soldiers uh in my commands that there
are times where a young Soldier will
choose to marry his Young Bride and
bring her and any children into a
military family
um and because the military treats its
families as part of the unit and and and
and and the institution of marriage is
there to uh they don't get insurance as
much as they get uh eligibility or
medical hospital to come in
um if if I think the military argument
is still that if a father or mother is
killed in combat and they've been
married to the spouse and the child
comes from that the psychology of it is
is that the children tend to be very
much better adjusted if they knew that
they were brought in to the world
through a process of recognizing and
committing to their love the the the the
other arguments that have been mentioned
here about high rates of domestic
violence I I think it was even mentioned
higher rates of HIV and AIDS higher
rates of divorce I I think I think these
are just general and I think the chair
mentioned this I think these are just
basically uh attacks on the institution
of marriage itself there's nothing that
was in that testimony that
differentiated that based on an age
difference that the these bad bad
negative things are more likely to
happen I I sort of believe in love still
I'm kind of a crazy guy that way and I
think if two people find themselves
um uh early uh that that it's entirely
possible to commit to it I'm reminded of
representative Harry Bean who many of
you know who he and his wife met at the
age of 15 and 16 and were married
shortly thereafter and after 50 years of
marriage they're still kicking around
and they're together so so we we we we
can't wrap this net of State control
over this entire demographic and treat
them as a unified group of people these
are all individuals trying to live their
lives
so let's say let's go back to the
pregnancy at the age of 16 or 17 after
the state has you know blessed the the
the conduct of sexual intercourse and
and and and the pregnancy exists if this
HP 34 were in place let's think about
this from the couple's perspective we
can't get married the state has taken a
position that bans us from getting
married much like we ban you know
huffing toxic Vapors we've banned
marriage as something that we perceived
to be toxic and I disagree with that so
what does what kind of choices do they
have well I think this turns out to be a
pro-abortion bill
because if they don't have the option to
get married then they got to start
looking at other ways of handling their
life circumstance and all of a sudden we
make abortion very easy uh and and
that's just social policy in New
Hampshire so all of a sudden abortion uh
gets to be a good option if they choose
to carry the baby to term it was
mentioned earlier about Medicaid so so
without the benefit of marriage the
propensity of going on Medicaid and
Welfare and other types of social
support uh increase it has the state
basically saying hey you can't get
married we're going to act like your
parent we're going to take care of you
as though we were your parents and I
don't think that's the role of the state
the other option is to go find a
sanctuary State we've talked about we've
heard about Sanctuary States so why
wouldn't there be a sanctuary state
where kids this age can go off and get
married and come back to New Hampshire
with the benefit of a marriage granted
by another state and under federal law
New Hampshire would be obligated to
recognize the sanctity of that marriage
so all we're doing is saying hey Drive
15 miles or whatever to go to Vermont or
Maine and get married and come back and
the state is irrelevant we've done
something ugly to you but don't worry
we're irrelevant because you can cross
state lines and get this taken care of
in the old days when I was young we
would call this shacking up that's
another option you could just choose to
live with each other without the benefit
of of marriage and I you know I don't
know there are advantages to that option
but I would encourage the the people to
seriously think through the the benefits
of stability that come with the with
marriage so uh so we if we take away
marriage as an option we're putting in
its place choices of abortion welfare
running away to Sanctuary States just
living in sin no it's not sin I mean
come on
that's a euphemism I don't actually mean
that but but you know what I'm saying
um we're giving we cannot control their
behavior even though this bill is trying
to control their behavior what we can do
is we can limit their options and force
them to take other options that are not
as attractive I don't think so I guess
in summary I would say
we need to think of this as an
individual Freedom issue how many people
have been married since the the bill
eliminated the ability of 14 and 15 year
olds to get married I I think we've
heard five and five years I don't I it
was hard because I we heard different
numbers in different contexts so this is
not a huge problem the problems that we
heard are historical you know the Grover
Cleveland for God's sake I mean that
didn't even happen in New Hampshire the
the the the the situation down in
Florida with a nine-year-old that that's
not New Hampshire and Florida does crazy
stuff all the time we're talking about
New Hampshire law we've already banned
14 and 15 we're allowing the individual
Freedom at this point for 16 and 17 year
olds and if we were talking today about
of 13 year olds ability to opt in to
having puberty blockers this entire
conversation would be flipped in an
instant and you you all know it all
right so um so let's try to achieve some
consistency on the principles of
individual freedom and and respect for
an institution that's vital I think to
providing social stability and and has
the best opportunity I think of creating
a safe and secure secure environment to
raise kids to be productive
um and um and really that's my testimony
so thank you
thank you representative any questions
for the representative
okay representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate that
um thank you representative Edwards for
being here and for your testimony and I
also thank you for your service to our
country
um as a question with that you did speak
about the military and people getting
married how important all that is to you
do you know what the age is that you can
legally uh sign up to be in the military
well it's uh it's 18 on your own I think
you can go down to 17. uh the age
actually changes depending on the needs
of the military and given they're in
such a tough recruiting situation it may
have been lowered but but the last I
knew it was 17 with the parental consent
and 18 with the on your own and uh and
if I may that that reminded me of
something else in New Hampshire and this
is this is the third fourth term this
issue fourth term this issue has come up
that I've been in and nobody has refuted
the process that we have here in New
Hampshire if you have somebody under the
age of 18 they need parental agreement
that the marriage license be issued and
then there's a magistrate review as well
to ensure that there's not internal
family coercion and the like and so the
the concerns about you know child brides
and people getting coerced we've put
we've built in safety uh
apps here in New Hampshire to try to
eliminate that I think we had a bill a
year or two ago that specifically made
coercion and marriage or abortion
illegal so
so I gave you a much longer answer than
you asked sorry follow-up representative
Greg yes I'm a learner I always
appreciate the information
um you also said that you are for the
sanctity of marriage yes which I am as
well
um do you know that the current would
you believe that the current statistics
for divorce are over 50 percent
I was married 41 years and I'm surprised
it's 50
and when you tell you the truth but that
does not because this is an individual
issue sure individuals make that
decision the state doesn't step in and
say 50 is unacceptable too many of you
are getting divorced we're going to set
up a marriage review board before
anything finished no I'm giving you my
answer still I'm I I understand the 50
but that does not create an opportunity
for the state to step in and add
additional regulation to an individual
Choice I'm very pro-choice as well and
sticking
representative Greg you can follow up
thank you and sticking with our mutual
agreement that the sanctity of marriage
is is a good thing
um would you believe that if you if for
children getting married under 18 that
statistic jumped up to 70 percent end up
in divorce
of the five kids that have been married
in New Hampshire since we changed the
law to prohibit under the age of 16 how
many of them have been divorced I mean
or you know let's talk about New
Hampshire
um are are do we know that there's any
problem with any of those five do we
want to go bust into any houses and pull
people apart and say you guys shouldn't
have gotten married we don't approve of
this conduct no
so I I I I do not think you can
strictly look at the choices of
individual freedom
on the basis of broad demographic
statistics
but we're okay with not being able to
hang on hang on hang on hang on what
it's it's no no no no no no it's it's
that's the signal for May I follow up
this is the signal for you got a whole
lot of newbie energy I know apologize
you're good and with all due respect
indeed
um but we're okay with uh making sure
that we limit military involvement until
18.
all right well they can get married or
excuse me they can go into the military
sooner than that and the military is
kind of a unique situation where we're
specifically trying to take people and
make them physically and mentally
capable going out and on order killing
others and breaking things so it's it it
it there's a kind of a high standard of
anti-social behavior that we ask the
military to get kids ready to perform
for us so it it be going into the
military is a different life choice than
puberty blockers or early marriage
okay we are now going to hear from
representative petrigno
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
what options uh does someone have under
the age of 18 if they're in a Loveless
or abusive relationship that they can't
get out of since divorce is not allowed
for individuals under the age of 18. how
do they how do they manage living in
that kind of a circumstance I'm not an
attorney I'm certainly not a family law
attorney I I I've heard it put into
testimony that uh that people under the
age of 18 can't go get a divorce
attorney and file for divorce this is
the fourth term this bill has come up
you would think that the sponsor of this
bill would have fixed that you know I I
would I would be a strong advocate of an
amendment that said you know filing for
divorce is a legal option at any age uh
and that and that's the standard way in
which we let people get out of the kind
of negative uh marriage that you just
described
thank you representative
uh thank you I'm looking forward to the
fifth term when we talk about this and I
hope you it all this
the chair recognizes Emma savini
from new futures
and the loving sister of Chloe you wish
we've had this chat before I think so I
do
you know
famous actress oh yes
and she's not related
so thank you representatives for hearing
my testimony today as mentioned my name
is Emma savini I am the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator at
new Futures which is a non-profit that
Advocates educates and collaborates for
the health and wellness of all Granite
Staters
we support this bill as a measure to
help improve children's Behavioral
Health across the state
children's Behavioral Health is a clear
priority for New Hampshire as evidenced
in the 10-year Mental Health Plan and
the continued
investments in our system of care
as you've heard from the bill sponsor
and other Advocates today child marriage
is often accompanied by parental
coercion in the forms of potentially
physical or emotional abuse
and physical emotional and sexual abuse
between spouses
these types of abuse are current
commonly referred to as adverse
childhood experiences when they occur
before the age of 18 those are often
abbreviated to Aces aces are widely
studied traumatic events that children
can experience during childhood and that
have lasting and devastating
consequences throughout life Aces have
been linked to negative consequences
such as poor education and job potential
they've been also linked to dangerous
Health consequences such as higher rates
of cancer diabetes heart disease back
pain and higher risk of suicide
um but there is hope
um Aces can be prevented the CDC cites
promoting social norms that protect
against violence and adversity as one of
the top ways for preventing Aces this
bill is a simple way to advocate for
that strategy
passing this legislation will continue
to advance New Hampshire's commitment to
ensuring that the granite state is a
safe place for all children
and I would encourage you and new
Futures would encourage you to vote this
bill OTP
happy to take any questions
I'm in awe that you were so articulate
in such a brief amount of time thank you
thank you chair recognizes
representative Nancy Murphy
[Music]
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee I'm Nancy Murphy I'm
co-sponsor of the bill and represent um
Hillsborough County uh
number District 12 the town of Merrimack
I'm here in support of HB 34.
um I just want to I agree and share my
perspective briefly on some of the
points made prior
um you know it goes without saying that
you know we've talked about marriage
being a legal contract and that children
cannot legally enter into such contracts
um representative Levick mentioned in
her testimony that
um you know this the question is you
know our 16 and 17 year olds
um do they know what love is and do they
understand that
and um you know I'd suggest that indeed
it is I met my husband when I was 15
years old dated for five years got
married when I was 20 and we've been
married for 44 years never dated another
person and I'm happily married
um and I realized how fortunate I was
um I was a junior in a nursing school at
bu at the time and my husband was three
years older than I was
um and I would suggest that much of the
reason that my life has been
um is easy in many ways as it was was
because number one
um I was allowed to continue my
education because I had really
supportive parents
um they had a home where we were able to
live in an apartment within that home
um and many kids now given housing
prices and tuition for schools
um you know an unplanned pregnancy or a
decision that they may enter into
because they love somebody
um but really don't get the big picture
of what comes down the line uh for me
it's been six children a lot of foster
children and I truly believe that
the foundation that I was afforded and
the time that I was afforded to grow up
and mature even with my husband at 20
we're now 64 and 66
um and you know we're we're
um just like anybody you know you you um
you're the same person you probably were
in many ways but you also grow and
develop and that was one of the other
things that was raised the difference
between you know well why 16 not 18.
um you know as a as a nurse too you know
I I think of the you know development of
the prefronto prefrontal cortex
um and that area of our brain is
responsible for things like planning
prioritizing controlling impulses
18 year olds are finishing up puberty
you have it you know these kids have a
greater uh sense of themselves
developmentally and a greater capacity
for developmenting developing healthy
romantic relationships I think what we
have the opportunity and the knowledge
and how to improve our kids lives and we
acknowledge their abilities and their
development I don't think we would ever
want to go backward
um you know and and we should look at
um uh you know making protecting our
kids protecting their future children
and Society in general by by passing
this bill so that's it short and sweet
you're not 64. I am yeah indeed
yes wow
I just get started young you know
thank you so much yeah thank you so much
representative the chair recognizes Lynn
Stanley and also uh I am now cutting off
no more pink cards we will finish the
three that we have
uh
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for hearing my testimony for
the record my name is Lynn Stanley I'm
the executive director of the National
Association of Social Workers New
Hampshire chapter representing over 800
members in our state
um and I'm I'm here urging you to uh
support
setting this bright line legislation
which means no exceptions I I guess I
would caution us about getting too much
into maturity right it is because this
isn't about maturity we may know 16 year
olds who are very mature we may know 50
year olds who are not it's not about
maturity it's about legal rights and
responsibilities
um that individuals obtain when they
turn 18 regardless of their maturity
level
a child cannot enter into legal
contracts like they can't secure housing
they can't secure legal assistance they
can't go to a domestic violence shelter
um
the 16 or 17 year old is still in most
ways legally a child and when married
they are now legally trapped by their
adult spouse as previously mentioned if
the father of a baby wants to co-parent
he can easily do so outside of marriage
by establishing paternity the baby could
be covered by his insurance
a service member can designate anyone as
the beneficiary of their service members
group life insurance regardless of
marital status
the numbers the very low numbers we have
very low numbers of children 16 and 17
year olds who are getting married
however New York and Massachusetts both
recently passed brightline legislation
meaning that they they've set the bar at
18. I'm also the executive director of
nasw Vermont working very hard to get it
passed in Vermont as well it is only a
matter of time before those numbers go
up
um we can anticipate this number Rising
given child marriage is a tactic used by
child traffickers to further control
their victims but now from a legal
standpoint taking a 16 year old across
state lines can be a federal crime
taking your wife across state lines is
absolutely okay
by setting no exception legislation and
only allowing those who are over the age
of 18 to marry
State shopping ends child rapists can be
punished and not wed to their victims
child trafficking under the guise of
marriage will end
and we basically can stop this form of
human slavery
thank you for hearing my testimony and
I'm very happy to answer any questions
you may have
the chair recognizes representative
petrigno thank you Mr Chad thank you for
taking my question uh if on your
testimony to be very compelling would
you be willing to submit something in
writing that we could have for the
record I have something in writing I'm
very I try to keep my written testimony
to one page I am very happy to I could I
could give you a thesis on this if if
you would like I'll keep it to this and
I'll turn it in thank you thank you
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you
what
oh I'm sorry I
representative panic I am so sorry
my first question too okay everyone pay
a special attention and representative
closer to the mic so we can hear every
word of it what really got my attention
is what you're talking about as a child
trafficking element of it and when we
know what's going on with the border
security issue a car down in Texas and
Arizona do are you anticipating
an increase of child marriages
I would not be surprised thank you for
the question I can't predict the future
I would not be surprised if the states
that are around
Massachusetts New York I believe
Pennsylvania New Jersey
I-93 is a corridor of all sorts of
uh stuff right and so if you're shopping
for where you can legally marry your 16
or 17 year old that you're trafficking
New Hampshire is the next stop up on 93.
so this is a nap follow-up no I want to
say one more thing so this is a national
security issue as well and we are also
trying to protect the children from
what's what's going on absolutely all
right thank you very much thank you
well done you're first
not bad yeah anyone else first or
otherwise
all right I have a card I'm gonna do my
best on this Dan or Don Albrecht
be again
your handwriting got a little worse from
the last card
that's because I banged it out you only
rescued it by good testimony so
uh Dana Albrecht National Albrecht
Nashua New Hampshire just very briefly I
point out the cultural norm widespread
these days is for people to have sexual
relations outside of marriage
uh number two I don't think the state
has any business regardless of gender or
orientation uh interfering what any two
people above the age of consent do
behind closed doors
uh with regard to those relations with
that said I have to ask what is the
state's policy uh concerning people
below the age of consent to have
relations with someone else changing
their gender or orientation and why
sort of a rhetorical question and lastly
there remains a cultural and religious
minority who sincerely held beliefs
uh or that they would prefer to wait uh
until after they are married to have
sexual relations
and I would just ask what the state's
policy is
towards uh to people who are above the
age of consent to have sexual relations
uh whether they're allowed to get
married first if those constitute there
are sincerely held religious beliefs uh
and again just
a question rhetorically for the
committee and I'm done I'm not really
prepared to answer questions okay but if
you have any I'll try
looks like you're off the hook thank you
normally state representatives go ahead
of the line unless they're on the
committee
that's why we're saving for last
uh representative Perez
you know my my wife who spent a year of
college in Mexico cannot her ours and I
can and she's jealous
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee
um with all the respect before I do my
testimony I want to be very clear that
um
I asked for permission to my kids and my
family to be about it testify and to
share
so
um I'm just going to say it in Spanish
because some of my my relatives they're
watching
um
Familia
para poder idea
is
the bill
um
victims
Ido casadas
okay so I'm gonna start
thank you everyone for listening to my
testimony today
my name is Maria Perez
I was born in El Salvador
I'm going to start by sharing that I was
raped
by my own father when I was five years
old
when I turned 15 years old
my parents met someone who was a U.S
citizen
they made an arrangement for that money
from him
a monthly
Samsung
and he brought me here
when I got here
I learned that he was previously married
three times he had five kids smaller
than me
he was an alcoholic
he was an abusive man
I didn't know the language
I didn't know my rights
I was abusive for 11 years
it's a minor
he used to get really drunk
beat me up
and when the neighbors used to call the
cops he used to hide me in the closet
when the cops used to knock the door
he used to open the door was one of the
kids who speak English opened the door
and said nothing is going on we just
having fun
I had black and blue eyes
I was sexually assault
by my stepkids
I lost a baby
when I was still a minor
I got beat up so many times
beat up
when I had my son at 22.
my mother
was what brought up by my ex-husband
here
with Ibiza went into the hospital and
forced me forced me
to sign
a letter saying that I want to get my
tubes die after I have my second child
the doctors say you're not 26.
and I say I know I don't want to get my
tooth tied
but my ex-husband and my mother made the
decision they didn't want me to have any
childrens with anybody else if I ever
get divorced from my ex-husband
I was forced to get my tubes tied
when I got divorced after all these
abused by my ex-husband I remarried the
love of my life my husband now
it was so hard for me to tell him
I wasn't nobody giving kids
because I was forced by my old mother
and my ex-husband
to get my style
that's why I'm here to let you know
that I'm asking all of you from this
community
to support this bill
and that's why since I got divorced
I told myself for the rest of my life
I will work hard
to support any big things not just from
sexual assault and domestic violence for
immigrants
like my salt
not just I got
sexual assaulted by my father but I was
sexual ass all at the border
escape from not getting pregnant by my
own father
I'm asking you to support this bill
because
even though that I trotted trying my
best to be strong
is this card that I always gonna have up
for the rest of my life
please support this bill
please pass this Bill thank you
thank you so much for that
this concludes the hearing
um if
if
the sponsor the prime sponsor of the
bill wishes to file any amendments that
is not a requirement but if you do you
got a couple weeks we won't take this
bill up for a couple of weeks maybe OSL
by then we'll find out the names well
they were told the names of your
co-sponsors and maybe they'll actually
put it on a piece of paper for you yeah
but that's up to you just let me know
uh that there was some things said about
the mill military requirements when
entering you have to be 18 if you are 17
or 16 you sign a promise and you can get
out of that at any point before you're
18 whether that's a few months or a year
and or a year or two and the military
has to say okay you get out and you also
have to have your GED we don't normally
take testimony after the hearing is over
but I appreciate that so next week same
place at 9 30 we're going to have a
another educational meeting with Richard
head from the justice department and
Cassandra Sanchez from the office of
child advocate
then at 10 30 we're going to take a look
um I'll go slow if you want to write it
down I'm we're going to take a look at
house bill 126.
this will be in the calendar but I'm
giving you advance notice 126 accrual
date for child support payments
representative Spillane
at 11 o'clock we hope to look at House
Bill 108
confidentiality of reports
representative Spillane
one o'clock
House Bill 151 committed to study
unmarried and that's representative
Maggiore
130 House Bill 218 court rules and
transcripts representative Bernardi 126
108 151 218 each of these is found on
the House website go under committees go
to Children and Family Law and then
punch up bills that are in our
possession and you'll have the entire
text of the bills
here
man
do we leave these or take them